Joe Rogan has canceled his sold out show
in Vancouver
and this is because of the vaccine
mandates on one of his most recent
episodes of his show with Tim Dylan he
said he didn't even think he could get
into the country now this was initially
reported by a lot of people that Joe
Rogan was considering canceling the show
but I think people people uh don't
understand that sometimes there's a
delay between when Joe records and when
he uploads like a lot of people were
saying like Tim you went on Joe's show
when you were in Austin and the show
didn't come out until you're already
back in in West Virginia but uh our
journalists made a very they did
something very simple
they did journalism and they checked the
Ticketmaster website which confirms the
event organizer has canceled the event
you will automatically get a refund and
based on what Joe had said in his show
so vaccine mandates man and so uh
tremendous respect for for Joe it may be
an issue of uh function
instead of perhaps politics or principle
just in that he couldn't even go to
Canada because of the vaccine mandates
so we've got that we've got fauci he's
saying that we should have vaccine
Medics for domestic air travel he's
telling people not to celebrate New
Year's
and we are in this limbo period between
Christmas and New Year's where nobody
wants to work it's amazing just all
today everyone's like is anything even
happening we don't want anything to
happen so you know I guess people don't
want to talk about it but I will say
there's a statement from Joe Biden it's
very important he basically gave up he
said there's no federal solution to
coven and instantly many people on the
left started tweeting outrage like this
is the guy I've said he was going to end
this and now he's saying there's nothing
I can do about it the state's got to
solve it and that means a lot coming
from a guy who was blaming Trump so we
got a lot to talk about we gotta talk
about hospitals and omnicron we got
Airbnb saying they're going to crack
down and investigate
and what's the right word
um violations of their terms for people
who engage in New Year's Eve parties or
something like this like Airbnb is not
going to have a New Year's Eve party
because of covid this is getting crazy
man
but joining us to talk about all of this
today is Mark loebliner how's it going
man man it's an honor to be here Tim
I'll tell you what what a beautiful
compound you have here appreciate you
got skate parks got chickens like this
is like every West virginian's dream
skate park uh maybe not that chicken
maybe maybe not but the chickens and the
compound and the do not enter signs I
had a great time just driving in here
man yeah yeah we had a lot of those
periods do not enter signs oh it's great
it's great man I loved it loved it but
thank you so much for having me on yeah
you want to explain a little bit about
who you are what you do so I'm the uh
CEO of a nutrition company called MTS
nutrition Chief marketing officer of a
nutritional supplement company website
called tigerfitness.com creator of the
outright bar which I think you see right
behind me right there and uh I have a
company called the Ambrosia Collective
also 015 nutrition I own alongside Mr
Olympia Brandon Curry pump Chasers I do
a few things also do online coaching
um the head strength coach for Ravenwood
high school wrestling in Brentwood
Tennessee so I I keep busy and I keep
really busy and you know at the end of
the day
you know I love my country and I'm here
to you know basically make my country
great whether that's through business
whether that's through educating kids
that's what I'm here for so I'm very
happy to be here to talk about man
appreciate it we got Luke chilling Mark
thanks for coming before starting I want
to address the treachery and blasphemy
that was committed on this show when I
couldn't be here by Mr Goldman and I
just wanted to State for the record that
I disliked Jack Murphy way before it was
cool and Jack was lying there wasn't a
fight before the show that was not true
but there will be and if you want to
finance my fight Camp you can by going
to thebestpoliticalshirts.com and buying
t-shirts like the one I'm wearing right
now depicting of course Dr Evil Mr Gates
and mini me Dr fauci saying just two
more weeks to slow the spread and uh you
can get that shirt support me Mark are
you going to be on my fight Camp oh
absolutely what is the fight camp but I
would love to fight who are we fighting
Jack Murphy
there was I want to make sure everyone's
clarified died Luke had he's got these
these professional martial arts trainers
doing like a you know like a real
training okay yeah Luke Luke's a little
off the cuff with it a little bit but
you know he said Jack Murphy came here
said there was a fight that he he took
me out and that therefore I wasn't on
the show that's clearly not true hashtag
Sydney Watson's lives matters there will
be a fight and watch out Jack uh we got
Mark here who's gonna be my strength and
conditioning coach here and it's only a
matter of time look at you some muscle
we got yeah we got you we got you all
right we got Lydia I'm also here in the
corner I'm very glad to be back from our
Christmas vacation we had a blast
enjoyed getting out and traveling a
little bit in defiance of Dr fauci and
all these other people trying to tell us
what to do really looking forward to New
Year's Eve I'm definitely going to be
celebrating then too so haha Christmas
vacation is not over for one Ian
Crossland that's right he's not here
Trader Ian is out for the holidays and
he'll be returning next week so before
we get started we got an awesome sponsor
go to
strongerbonesandlife.com and you can get
the Ageless multi-collagen from BioTrust
I love the stuff I mix it in my drinks
it's really good and uh I'm I'm an old
man I'm 35 I'm soon to be 36 and I've
got a skate park as we were mentioning I
skate all the time I was skateboarding
and rollerblading today and my knees oh
oh so achy but I've been taking this
stuff I've been mixing in my drinks and
I gotta say if you if you care about
your skin your nails your joints and all
that stuff you definitely want to go to
strongerbones in life.com pick up your
ageless multi-collagen and you will get
a 60-day money-back guarantee you get
five key types of collagen you need from
four different sources hydrolyzed
collagen peptides meaning better and
faster digestibility to support maximum
benefits and for every order today they
will donate a nutritious meal to a
hungry child in your honor through their
partnership with no kidhungry.org to
date BioTrust has provided over 5
million meals to Hungry kids please help
them hit their goal of 6 million meals
this year there is nearly no odor or
taste unlike bone broth or other
collagen supplements there's no clumping
unlike other collagen supplements and
you will get free shipping with every
order free VIP live health and fitness
coaching from BioTrust team of expert
nutrition and health coaches for life
with every order and their new e-report
the 14 foods for amazing skin with every
order again that is that is stronger
bones and life.com shout out thanks so
much BioTrust but don't forget to go to
timcast.com become a member to support
all of our Fierce and independent
journalists as a member you will also
get access to exclusive segments from
the timcastiro podcast which will be up
tonight at 11 PM you don't want to miss
them they're good fun and don't forget
to smash that like button right now
subscribe to this channel share the show
with everybody you know seriously you're
going it's New Years you're going to be
surrounded by all of your loved ones and
you are going to be like you guys need
to watch the timcast IRL podcast and
then the arguments will begin and you'll
accuse each other of being a libtard and
an alt-right and whatever but you can be
like Tim I'm kidding but uh yeah shout
out to the show you really do like the
show and let's get into that that first
big story this one I think is actually
very amazing
from timcast.com Joe Rogan sold out
Vancouver's show canceled due to vaccine
mandates quote I don't even think I can
get into the country Rogan said comedian
podcast host Joe Rogan said it sold out
April show in Canada is unlikely to it
to take place because of the vaccine
mandates now I'll tell you something
when I first saw this clip from Joe on
his show where he was like I don't think
we can do the show
I was immediately like whoa whoa is
anybody writing up is there other more
details on this so I sent it to our
Newsroom which is supported by members
at timcast.com and I was like can you
guys look into this pull it up and they
write this story Joe Rogan sold out
Vancouver show canceled I immediately
was like whoa whoa oh guys guys he
didn't cancel the show he's saying he
might cancel and they were like no no
Tim don't worry we fact checked it it's
true from ticketmaster.ca event canceled
unfortunately the event organizer has
had to cancel your event no actioners
are required to obtain a refund it will
be processed to the original method of
payment yada they go on and that's it
Joe Rogan goes on his show says he
doesn't think he can do the show and
then we get confirmation from
Ticketmaster the Show is canceled good
on Joe Rogan
good for him I don't know if he actually
canceled the shot of principle it may
just be function like he literally can't
get into Canada so you can't have the
show but I think people need to start
realizing this I was having a
conversation with some friends and
family if you keep enabling these
lunatics they will keep pushing until
you say no and make them understand
there will be consequences for this so
This Stadium this city you're going to
lose all of that money from one of the
most famous comedians in the world yeah
I don't know if Joe had a choice here
because Canada is not allowing anyone
who's not vaccinated into their country
so there's a lot of other people like
Jim Brewer who had to cancel their shows
because they clearly just weren't
allowed to be in Canada at all and that
is absolutely ridiculous Joe Rogan has
antibodies he went through coronavirus
he he got on the other side he of course
used Alternatives he didn't take the
vaccine but but he clearly has you know
antibodies within him that that prevent
him from from getting sick from the
basic understanding of it isn't isn't
this the goal of the vaccine right
someone said this to me they were like
the goal of the vaccine is to trigger an
immune response in your body so it
produces antibodies right yeah so if you
have the antibodies it's effective like
what's the difference well it clearly
has something to do more with just
protecting People's Health and there's
something larger play I'm not pretending
to know what that is but the thing we
need to look at now is not why he
canceled it but the fact that it got
canceled and suppliers need to cut off
companies or countries or venues that
literally take away people's personal
freedom to make a choice on whether they
want to take this medical procedure or
not that's the key by Joe Rogan doing
this it sends a message directly to
their pocketbooks directly to their
ability to generate income and at the
end of the day money is what solves this
and that's how we solve this is we cut
off the supply
I think a lot of people will think about
this in the sense like Joe Rogan's Rich
right so they're like okay he's
canceling the show how how much will
this one show impact the bottom you know
his bottom line but I think the bigger
thing is
there's probably I mean I think it's
fair to say tons of smaller shows that
got canceled and wiped out we learn all
about the small businesses that were
shut down in the lockdowns now with
vaccine mandates we've seen all of these
reports from various cities about how
their business drops by like 30 percent
what you're not going to hear in the
news is Small Time comedian who packs
you know maybe 50 people into a room
unlike Joe Rogan who sells out of
Stadium you get one small comedian who
travels around doing these comedy shows
opening acts and his career is done yeah
there's no more income there's no more
show and it's whether they want to do it
or not but like I was just saying
there needs to be consequences the
problem is if this stuff keeps happening
then our culture is being ripped apart
no comedy show from Joe Rogan Joe
Rogan's literally the guy who goes up
there and Rags on all this stuff so if
he's not doing this then people aren't
hearing it they're getting their
opinions filtered through social media
it's a tricky problem man I think
there's probably a lot of people
involved with these shows because you
need to understand people need to
understand this is not just like Joe
shows up and a show happens I mean
you've got crew you've got vendors
you've got marketing companies you've
got the stadium you've got insurance
this is probably going to be Millions
upon Millions maybe maybe seven or eight
figures in terms of Revenue going into
this
now gone yeah and it's a government and
this yeah all nonsensical non-scientific
policies even the UK government did a
study saying vaccine mandates don't
actually help anything here they do
promote people to get the vaccine which
is uh they're all end-all belief system
here but but as we know here the data is
still very early there's still a lot of
conflicted information we don't know
exactly what's going on here but but to
close off from business to close off
from individuals to restrict people's
ability to travel based on this notion
that we still haven't figured out that
we still don't know the consequences of
is ridiculous this is this is the this
is the problem of people complying this
is the problem of all these experts
these Democrats are otherwise who are
telling everybody you have to abide by
these restrictions but then are caught
not abiding by them which clearly shows
you want to call my hypocrite fine but
these you know Gretchen Whitmer is it a
bar Gavin newsom's at a restaurant Nancy
Pelosi's getting her hair done they're
not scared at all whatever it is they do
whatever it is they know they're not
scared of this now I'm not I don't know
but if your attitude is I'm gonna pass
all these rules and then we're going to
ignore them you're sending a huge
message to people not to take this
seriously but are people listening to
the message you still got it appears to
be a large percentage of population who
listen to falsi who listen to Pelosi who
listen to Biden who clearly looked down
on them as peasants and do exactly the
opposite of what they tell us to do so
the question is where are these people
when are these people going to wake up
when are they going to be like hey how
come Biden's walking around and the
servers are one way and he's the other
way when they can't get their pizza when
they can't go to their comedy show when
they're when they're now being
confronted uh like in Chicago they're
doing the vaccine mandate on the third I
talked to a lot of people in Chicago who
are like all of a sudden hey man what's
this you know I did everything I was
told that everything right now they're
going to do more mandates well that's
right did you think you could comply
your way out of tyranny well it goes
from from the actual like shots went
from okay you get two and you're done
now it's like nah you need three Israel
I think did four right they're already
implementing for the fourth Israel is
going to be up to 10 by the end of the
year and it's the freaking 27th what was
that what was that ad there was like a
billboard that was going viral I haven't
fact checked this but it's like an ad
that says your coveted vaccine is like a
battery it needs to be recharged so it
was only the United Kingdom
um that released it and it literally
said you got to take the booster to make
sure you have immunity but that destroys
the definition of vaccine that's not a
vaccine well hold on tons of vaccines
have boosters like when I got yellow
fever I had to get I had to get a
booster after six months but so quickly
I mean we're talking about how long how
long do you have to get a booster
with the with the other one yellow fever
okay that I was wrong on that one yeah
I'm like look I think the bigger issue
is policy it's that they promised us
people abided by this and then the terms
change it's literally Darth Vader being
like the terms of the deal have changed
probably I don't alter them further it's
like at this point you're going to I
know you're going to so now people are
losing all Faith losing faith in any
look it's it's almost annoying to even
bring up because we've all lost faith in
this yeah Joe Biden coming out and being
like you need to get vaccinated now
because there's a winter of death inside
offering and I'm like bro your words are
meaningless to me completely meaningless
you can say it over and over again every
single person can come out and say the
exact same thing yo we're well beyond
the point where those words have any
meaning yeah and it's and what's
happening now the point that I should
have made here is that it's the exact
opposite of what they promised it would
be they never said from the beginning
hey this is going to be temporary it's
going to wane you're going to need to do
this every couple months they never said
that they said one and done that's it
you're fine here just take this
everything will go back to normal it
clearly hasn't it clearly hasn't worked
a lot of people that I talk to I talked
to a lot of people in New York City over
the last few days they're they're
disenfranchised they're they're confused
they're like they don't know what to
believe anymore but I think the
sentiment nationally is that people are
kind of sick of it they're they're sick
of the fear-mongering and and they have
been essentially told almost every
single day they're gonna die they're
gonna die unless they comply and a lot
of them have been complying but we're
reaching a point where a lot of them are
like looking around being like what's
the point like why should I I'm I'm I'm
completely burned out on all of this
stuff I got covered it was the the worst
sickness I ever got I say that a lot it
was it was bad I I genuinely thought I
was like about to go to the hospital and
then I got the monoclonal antibodies and
all that stuff I actually had medical
intervention on this it's bad
but I want to live
I wanna you know out here where we are
we go to the movies it's totally fine I
was in Chicago and they have a city-wide
mask mandate and half the people aren't
even abiding by it not a single person
ever told me I had to wear a mask or
whatever it just doesn't make sense I
walk into a restaurant and I'm like do I
really got to put this on for literally
five seconds because my table is right
there and then you sit down and take it
off I'm like what are what are we doing
with this like I understand if you want
to say there should be a mask man it
slows the spread well then everyone
should be wearing them their masks the
entire time they're in the building but
they're not doing it no one's doing it
it's not being taken seriously now
they're they're they're like okay we're
gonna do a vaccine mandate for the city
then then then what's gonna happen
people aren't going to abide by it well
that we're just good I guess we never
did it right like there are specific
protocols for how you use masks you
touch it you throw it away yeah once you
touch it it's gone if they were serious
if this was serious if masks we might
say Max work if masked actually masks
actually did what they were supposed to
do there's a really great video showing
they do what they're supposed to do the
problem is like even fauci has brought
this up very early on he's like you
touch it and you're you're getting you
know what did he say you're getting
shorts what's on it and stuff it's like
you said it's really simple to come out
and say masks work well of course
doctors wear them for a reason the
problem is a bunch of people look I was
walking through Chicago every mask was
under their nose and no one says a word
and I'm like what's the point if you're
not going to actually tell people to fix
it if you if you don't care nobody cared
I guess my point is everybody's just
burned out on this I'm so burned out I'm
so sick and tired of talking about it
two years man well we're not wearing the
proper masks if we actually had n95s
fitted and if you touch it you throw it
away you wash your hands and scrub them
and surgeons are wearing them for
different reasons in the hospital
setting they only wore them during
surgery I never had a doctor come out to
me at a hospital I spent a lot of time
in the hospital as a kid because my mom
would be in and out of hospitals my dad
was really sick never once the doctor
come out with a mask that wasn't a thing
they put it on to prevent getting
splattered in the face by some
projectile kidney fluid or or the other
with them spinning but but to prevent to
actually walk around and think this is
going to stop something microscopic and
n95s do but you have to fit them right
no no I I this is we had this argument
before with somebody because Steve was
it Steve yeah uh you can get coveted
through spit and through aerosolized you
know water Vapors yeah so the masks stop
the spin well they stopped the spit but
they they're still stuff going through
them it does reduce the viral load I
will admit it's a spit and if there's
viruses in the spit so my thing is just
basically my point is this not MediCal I
I really could I I really don't care to
have medical arguments about dying and
Doffing or whatever I think you make a
good point about proper way it's called
donning and Doffing right yes when
you're how you're supposed to put it on
how you supposed to take it off it's
just people like literally with these
nasty unclean masks my thing is just if
nobody cares anymore if people in
Chicago aren't abiding by it and they're
like we're gonna up the mandates I just
don't see how this just just it's over
like the the policies people are fed up
in Chicago I'm getting I'm hearing
people complain about this saying I
can't believe how insane it's getting
I'm not going to do this and I'm hearing
people saying they're going to leave and
then we look at there's there's this
graph that's been going around on
Twitter showing California New York
Illinois largest population Exodus in
the Country Florida and Texas major boom
in population people are voting with
their feet they're saying I don't care
I'm done I'm out well they're they're
voting and they're moving away from from
government because government almost
every step of the way here made the
situation that much worse for masks Dr
fauci and and the CDC were telling
people from the very beginning you don't
need masks then you need masks then you
need two masks then you don't need two
mats again the messaging was always
confusing we never prioritized early
treatment we never talked about building
up the terrain fighting obesity helping
people's immune systems we never talked
about a lot of the issues that could
have according to some medical
professionals really made an impact here
it was always one procedure one product
the vaccine always we need to do that
and that that to me was was just uh a
misnomer and a lot of people are asking
serious questions about that specific
stance last year
I can't remember exactly when it was but
I was listening to Joe Rogan's show and
he started he was talking about covid
again and I was like we're all locked
down it's hard to fly people and get
guests we were we didn't even have
guests until like August of last year
when restrictions started to ease and I
was just listening to the show and I was
like
you know
Joe has the best one of the biggest and
best podcasts in the world and even he
is just talking about covet over and
over again and I'm like are we seriously
now it's been two years and I can't tell
you how much of the content we've done
is literally just covered
yeah it's just crazy to me that we're
still in this Matrix world of this is
life this is life it's all it is all the
news all the big stories is just how bad
are things getting now and I'm like
last week you know I'm like hey Luke
before the show like what's the big
stories and Luke's like we got this on
kova these protests and I'm like yo I
don't care I was like I can't talk about
this stuff let's talk about something
else yeah now now we're we're you know
what ended up happening is
DC Baltimore Philly I'm not sorry not
Baltimore uh Boston Philly Chicago they
all announced these these mandates
right before Christmas when no one's
paying attention when no one knows
exactly what's going on and I got them
talking to people and they're like wait
what's happening and I'm like you didn't
hear us Chicago is going to require you
to get a vaccine and they're like I
didn't I didn't know I'm like yeah
because people are with their families
and so all this news dumps the same time
everybody wants to have a good time and
they want to think about fun family
stuff and here we are once again it's
been two years who I I can't remember
who this was they said zooby I think it
was he said my VOC my vocabulary on
covet is officially gone I'm not going
to talk about it ever again I don't care
anymore and I'm like I feel I think it
was Ubi maybe I'm just like I feel you
man
I'm burned out on this so much nothing's
changed I mean things keep changing but
they say the same you know in a certain
way in that 15 days to slow the spread
becomes three months becomes where a
mass becomes wear two mask I get it by
next year we'll all be wearing gigantic
plastic bubble suits and what will be in
our 10th booster shot is that where
we're going look I'm just gonna go I'm
gonna take care of the chickens I'm
gonna skate we've got we we have a
bottle of trump champagne we're gonna be
cracking open on New Year's and I'm
gonna live my life so Tim here's a
question back to the masks real quick
when do we get to take them off like
okay we know they do so okay let's say
they work when do we get to let our kids
see each other's facial expressions what
do you mean take them off no no no no no
no you gotta put more on Dr fauci
Dr fauci today said came out he said
don't even consider removing your masks
when you're on the flight yeah that
guy's nuts at the end of the day you
know you have a situation where there's
always going to be some stuff floating
around in the air there's always going
to be something dude I was taken down
for five days by hand foot and mouth
disease he's from going to a children's
museum I couldn't walk my hands
literally sloft off I had no fingernails
and I wasn't like man I wish I wore a
mask and I was like oh shoot I got a
virus maybe I should take better care of
my health or maybe I should look into
what vitamins prevent viruses instead of
like oh let me cover my face and force
my kids to cover their face and fly with
a facial covering that's absurd that's
insane you know I was thinking I was
like
we could mandate a whole lot of things
to keep people safe I made this joke on
Twitter I was like let's mandate morning
calisthenics I think that's great I'm
down
I'll be jumping jacks I don't care get
rid of fast food uh you know let's get
rid of them on Santos gotta keep
Chipotle in there I don't know about
that I don't know he's good it's got
chicken and rice chicken recipe
I am taking offense he's an anti-body
Bill diet
yes I think I think I think you know why
I love going to Chipotle
because they've got you your meal is
going to be fats and proteins yes I I
don't I don't do the rice and the beans
oh I do the hell out of rice man I'll do
a whole lot of drugs in this body come
on I will I will get the the peppers and
onions the chicken and then I'll be like
cheese guacamole sour cream perfect you
can make your perfect meal kind of a
low-fat high protein diet you could have
a high fat um high protein diet you
could have well you could have a vegan
diet like I'm sorry Chipotle Moe's Qdoba
if you're looking for fast food that can
actually fit whatever diet you're on I'm
I'm sipping for those guys man that's
some good that's some good eating let's
let's let's let's uh let's talk about
what you did okay so for those that
aren't familiar Mr uh lobliner right I'm
pronouncing it right low blinders good
liner you're Tim you call me whatever
you'd like I screwed it up so you you
have the we have these this box of uh uh
what do you call it it's a whole food
bar right yeah it's the uh it's it's a
whole food protein bar it's called the
outright bar sitting right behind you
yes and you announced just I think it
was not even two weeks ago yeah that you
were pulling out a of Kroger
supermarkets because of their coveted
policies yes
um and that was a decision that I woke
up and I read the news and I'm like you
know what I just can't sit back and be
complicit look I am not anti-v word not
I'm not at all my kids all have them I
have them but under this circumstance
and situation some people might not be
able to get these I mean I believe Lydia
you can't get you can't kill me not to I
I was told I'm not supposed to get it by
my doctor so they're saying that we're
going to penalize you for not getting
this and there's no one fighting for the
employees these guys are alone no one's
fighting for them you got Biden's
Administration saying that if companies
don't do this they're killing grandma
and they're complicit in whatever you're
losing money on this I'm losing money
yes you say how much money or do you
want to keep that private seven figures
millions of dollars Kroger is huge
they're huge they own other things like
Ralphs like it's a segue into the door
wow we're in the final steps of the
conversations and I was like I woke up
in the morning and I ran it by my wife
now you guys don't know me as well as my
wife knows me rightfully so but I have a
I kind of have the tendency to do things
a little rash little brass you know a
little bit spur of the moment like I
don't think things through so I actually
did and I'm like Katie what should I do
she's like this is the right decision
because
for me it hits hard it hits home because
being complicit when you have this kind
of tyranny and this kind of fascism take
over
that's what led to World War II Oh Mark
you can't compare this to Nazis yes I
can
yes I can it's the same path and by the
way I lost my entire family to Nazis in
World War II the only reason I'm here is
because my grandfather escaped Auschwitz
and because people like me who own
businesses people who can influence
people to do the right thing they stood
by and just said oh we'll be okay let me
just take care of my family today oh I
could pay my bills today I'm fine oh I
got money in the bank I'm fine until the
government comes confiscation puts you
on a train and that's what happens and
if we don't stand up to government
overreach like this my goal with this
was to get other companies to follow but
they have no spines and they are greedy
bastards
absolutely give me another hour I have a
lot more to say oh we got we got an hour
and a half oh cool all right so so
sitting behind uh just right right
behind
um Mark is his outright bars which uh
they're delicious yeah we have a bunch
they're amazing and it's like peanut
butter honey and all that good stuff
protein yeah it's Whole Food protein bar
yeah you did the right thing man you you
wrote a letter to Kroger saying we
cannot in good conscious support this
but it's not just about what governments
are doing it's about what these
businesses are doing you stood up to
Kroger you stand to lose a lot of money
by doing it yes and there are so many
people who are like I won't take that
risk like you said I'll just take care
of my family and what you end up with is
one step at a time things get worse the
more people are willing to tolerate the
more the the evil pushes and encroaches
until finally someone says enough I'm
not going to stand for this look Tim me
going on an airplane and refusing to
wear a mask and getting arrested nobody
cares it's not going to make a change
what I want to do is make a change from
this level and hopefully other companies
follow and that's where I'm that's where
I'm at with this it's like okay I'm one
product out of thousands and thousands
of products at Kroger they don't care
they can live without the outright bar
you know what and you know what I'm
gonna be just fine I'm gonna pay my
bills I'm gonna be just fine my kids are
gonna be fine
but if I didn't make this stand who's
going to lead the way who's going to be
the first one to say hey I'm not putting
up with this anymore I'm not gonna stand
by and watch them abuse their employees
and I'm not going to stand by and watch
the government overreach on people's
freedoms and rights like we talked about
earlier it's not about whether the
medical procedure is safe or not it's
about Freedom yep it's about choice and
I'm not going to stand by in the
greatest country the greatest country
that ever existed in the history of this
planet and let these bastards destroy it
I'm not going to do it not on my watch I
saw a viral video of this nurse or one
claiming to be a nurse saying they fired
her for not getting vaccinated and then
they called her up they sent her a text
saying can you come back and work
because we're desperate it's like well
consequences man they brought back Kyrie
Irving yeah because the vaccinated
players got sick with coven and he's the
unvaccinated nurses are irrelevant Kyrie
Irving is the big loss to society right
and that guy dude not only does he have
tremendous game but his shoes are really
nice nice huge fan of the kyries
but what you were saying about Kroger
was was a very important moment because
they took a step further than a lot of
other corporations out there they
decided to say we have a whole bunch of
people working for us helping make this
this company they they put their Blood
Sweat and Tears into it and we're going
to set a policy that takes away their
benefits away from them if they don't
take a medical procedure that we want
them to take which is absolutely crazy
it's mind-boggling and the people
working for for Krogers should be
thinking twice about who they're working
for when they have management like that
and there was a lot of protest against
Kroger there's there's also a lot of
people saying Kroger wants to move into
Florida a lot of people were organizing
a lot of different efforts to say hey
we're not going to support this business
we're going to vote with our dollar you
took it to another level which I think
is commendable because you absolutely
put you know your blood you're sweating
your tears on the line for for Freedom
we I talk about this all the time about
how people are unwilling to sacrifice to
do what's right you did exactly that and
and then some I mean look man
seven figures in sales you could buy
yourself something real nice and fancy
but instead you said Freedom's more
important so you you bought you spent a
lot of money but you bought Freedom at
least a little bit well Mike what
example look I have three kids I have a
soon to be 16 year old girl a 13 year
old boy and another eight-year-old boy
what example am I saying to my children
if I don't take a stand what example am
I saying to my children if I don't put
principle over profit what example does
that set for the kids that I coach at a
high school level what world do you
leave behind We Leave Behind a really
crappy world that resembles countries
that have never made it America is the
last standing Beacon of Freedom we need
to keep it that way and it starts look
I'm an idiot I'm a meathead okay I get
it I get all the jokes I see all the
comments on Twitter I know what you guys
think about me okay at the end of the
day if an idiot like me can do his part
and if you agree with look if you agree
if you don't agree with me by all means
don't don't sacrifice anything but if
you agree that what's going on now is
the wrong thing you need to local effect
can have a global change you need to
affect local that's what you need to do
do your part I'm not saying do something
stupid and get arrested but I know
there's something that all of us can do
to help change I'll tell you this
one thing you can do for those that are
watching is if there is if you have a
Kroger or well known Ralphs in other
stores if you don't like the policies
they're implementing do not shop there I
don't I I go to Publix I that Kroger's
the course Publix was really good
weren't they I love Kroger I do I always
went there and that's why this hurts so
bad also our our company
tigerfitness.com and outright bar work
headquartered in Loveland Ohio which is
Cincinnati basically and that's where
they're located so I actually had you
know there were some of my colleagues
who were not too happy with this
decision because it's a local company
but this is about more than just
Cincinnati this is about the world the
best the best layup we ever had on one
of our sponsor ad reads was when Michael
malice was on the show and I'm like we
do the shout out for you know our very
sponsors and Michael just interjects he
was like guys these companies that are
sponsoring shows like this are the
companies you need to be supporting
because they're putting themselves on
the line we know how cancel culture
works we know that people come after
companies I'm getting kicked out of
stores or canceled off you know certain
shows they threaten advertisers you need
to support the businesses that are
actually putting something on the line
to defend these values yeah so
you're walking away from a fat paycheck
and there's a lot of people it kind of
bums me out but look I should put it
this way we should be air we should be
standing on the side of optimism for
what you've done with your company and
the things you're saying it can be
discouraging sometimes like where's
everybody else where where are the other
businesses that have values that are
have products in Kroger are going to be
like we're going to follow suit we're
gonna do the same thing because I'll
tell you this Salvation Army they got
called out recently because they had
some critical race Theory stuff on their
website how fast did they backpedal and
apologize when donors started canceling
saying I will not fund this if people
start saying if you're a good company
that does the right thing I want to be I
want to help encourage your growth the
funny thing is the left says the exact
same thing and the right isn't playing
the game the left will be like guys
everyone go and support these companies
that are that are engaging in practices
that support our values support these
companies and they do it they organize
they get Collective and the rights like
I don't really care I'll go to Kroger
and buy one no no it's it's time to
start voting with your dollars and
voting with your feet and saying I'm not
going to support companies that are
sacrificing us and people need to
understand like like voting with your
with your money voting with your dollars
voting with your time with your
attention with your voice absolutely
matters to such a huge degree that if it
didn't that that all hope would have
been lost but there's been so many
different effects there have been so
many different people standing up for
the right thing and there's been a huge
suppression of it and and Mark I I think
you know you stand by these these basic
ideas you know this basic idea of Fame
and money is worthless in life
especially at the end of life compared
to of course your values the life you
lived what you stood up for in the world
you left for your children I think that
is a lot more important and at the end
of the day even though you lost out on
some money I think you made the right
decision and I think people will support
you and I think energetically
synchronistically things are going to go
your way a lot more because of people
standing up against people getting
discriminated against because let's just
say you know Linda was working at
Kroger's he almost said Lydia I know I
had to correct myself there we have an
ongoing inside joke here that's another
story but but like if if you were
working there right you would have had
your benefits taken away right before
the holiday season you would have been
denied basic access basic help to
survive in this world because of your
own personal medical decisions that your
doctor says you can't take so that's
absolutely insane and crazy and then
that deserves to be protested minimally
uh at least with your dollars for just
for the segment people are wondering
what where they can pick up so the
easiest place is tigerfitness.com we're
also available at every single vitamin
shop locally if you have a grocery store
HyVee HEB we're available at awesome
local retails Natural Body in New York
we've got everybody nutrition in
Huntington Beach we have over we have
tens of thousands of gas stations that
carry our bars we're out there we're out
there and you know at the end of the day
we're doing this for the employees of
Kroger believe it or not it might seem
like it's hurting their company we're
trying to change policy we're trying to
make it so they have no choice but to
say hey we made an error and then talks
resume immediately they resume
immediately I just want them to realize
their errors and this is not a good
thing this is not about this is
pro-freedom this is absolutely Pro
freedom and also one more thing when
you're talking about what what the
benefit is when I die and one day I will
die okay
my no one's going to remember me for the
car I drove no one's going to remember
me for the house I owned or the
companies I had if you remember me for
what I did and the actions I took
they're going to remember me for
coaching at a high school level on my
own time for free you'll remember me the
kids are gonna remember me hey that's
the guy who taught me how to deadlift
correctly that's the guy who helped me
win a State title they don't give a crap
that I did five million dollars a year
in Kroger nobody's gonna care and my
kids they're gonna be just fine but
they're not going to care either because
when they talk about their dad and talk
about what kind of person I was not how
much money I made one of the things I I
that really I've always complained about
people not standing up for themselves I
remember when I was younger I had a
friends friends who were servers at
restaurants and they'd be like we need
to vote you know this way or that way
because they need to raise the minimum
wage not fair we only get paid three
bucks an hour whatever and I was like
why don't you quit my friends are back
well I need the job and I'm like do all
of your co-workers agree with you that
you're not paid enough that the the base
rate for a server is too low and they're
like yeah yes and I'm like so you mean
to tell me that each and every one of
you could just be like hey we're all
going to quit unless like you could
strike and they're like oh I don't know
about that I'm like yo if you were all
for this you need to just say it the
problem is they all feel that everyone
else is a coward
this person working there is like well I
would but then I get fired because no
one else will and I'm like well then you
work with cowards and if if all of you P
if everyone working there just said I
don't want to work in these conditions
your wages would Skyrocket overnight and
the cost of food might go up there's
repercussions here but you know
if people are unwilling to take that
stand because no one else will then we
we are in a downward trajectory if you
take the stand or if anyone takes the
stand you may be the only one standing
that may be the case but at least you
voted exactly how you needed to vote
this is what I tell people I don't vote
for party I don't care I don't like the
two-party system show me something worth
voting for Donald Trump last year he did
2016. he didn't in 2020 I saw things I
liked it I want to vote for that I
really do and I don't like voting
against people I'd rather vote for a
Libertarian candidate or uh depending on
the nowadays maybe not a green Party
candidate but I'd rather vote third
party because I vote for what I believe
in because if you vote for what you
believe in you've never wasted your vote
but everybody is scared they're scared
of the other they're scared if I vote
for this guy then this guy's going to
win well then we all lose is that what
we're going to do no I'm not about that
so I got a lot of respect for what you
did by standing up and putting your own
company in the line putting putting your
bottom line on the line because some
things are more important very yeah it's
no question it was the right choice no
question at all let's talk about how
insane people are with this stuff
because apparently the only news is
covered news all right there's this
viral video this one was awesome foul
mouth Delta passenger who was arrested
for spitting at and punching 80 year old
man for not wearing a mask while he ate
despite her not wearing one either is
revealed to be a luxury real estate
agent and former raiderette man so he
got she spit in his mouth in his mouth
all in the name for fighting covet
honestly I would pay good money to have
a raiderette spit in my life
hey hey family friendly
that was good that was that was one of
my better ones thank you I'm just gonna
leave right now so that was a good one
so this lady is in this viral video
she's on the plane and there's a guy
minding his own business and he's like
eating and she's screaming at him wait a
mask
why have people gone insane I think you
know what I think misery loves company
this lady sees a guy sitting there not
wearing the mask and she thinks if I
have to wear it so does he and she gets
mad yep and so she goes up and starts
screaming at him and then the FBI
arrests her now she's going to go to
jail
there's another viral video where a guy
is stalking him in a supermarket and he
actually says is does anyone else has
anyone else pissed that we all have to
wear masks and she isn't that's the
mentality of these people they are like
children they're like well if I have to
you have to ah it's like bro is anyone
telling you to they're not telling her
to take your mask off there's clearly no
enforcement but do you think it's that
or you think it's just that people who
are really bad at life suddenly have the
opportunity to exert power over others
because I just i s the people I see
doing this like you don't see dudes and
I hate to be a bit like I just I don't
want this to sound arrogant but you
don't see dudes who are built like me
going up like put your mask on no it's
always little pipsqueaks with really bad
facial hair
it's really true so I think it gives
betas a chance to feel Alpha because I
don't have the urge like I get to bark
at high school kids every day and say
get your set you know I don't have the
urge to and yell at someone I think it's
lower than
that's part of the larger kind of
psychological conditioning that happened
because you saw the corporate media
repeat you could be a hero you could
save lives grandma could have an extra
year of life if you do your part if you
wear your mask and they heard that
message over and over again and they
also saw Grandma and old people dying in
in horrible horrific ways just
broadcasts to them 24 7 non-stop by the
corporate media and it's ingrained in
their psychology that if someone doesn't
wear a mask they're trying to kill me
and this lady there's reports of her
being drunk whatever it is I think was a
victim of that larger kind of mind
control psychosis and and she truly
believed he's hurting someone by not
wearing a mask I think misery loves
company I think you have people like
Bill Maher he went on his show and he
was like I took one for the team I got
two shots and now they're saying I gotta
do more I'm not gonna do it that's Bill
Maher breaking out of the mold yeah
there's a lot of people who are scared
to
so what ends up happening is they get
their third shot I've talked to some
people man and the reaction was is is
really strange yes I was talking to
someone recently
about um restrictions vaccine mandates
in cities and they I didn't say anything
political I was just like wow I mean
it's going to be you know I was like
things are going to get interesting with
these mandates and they're like who
cares it's totally fine it's totally
it's it's totally no big deal at all
I've got all of my shots and I was like
all right like
that was that was a quick escalation
like there's an agitation in their voice
and my response was like yeah but you
know some places they're now saying like
you it's after nine months in Germany or
whatever it doesn't matter I'll get it
I'll get it it's fine and I'm like all
right slow down dude like what I'm
hearing in this is there are people who
are unsure of themselves and they're
scared so they want to feel comfort
knowing everyone else is in the same
position they are
so when they say I went and did this
because I had to I don't know if it was
the right thing I'll feel better if
everyone else has to do the same thing
but people are refusing
I think what's happening is there are
people who don't want this is the danger
of the vaccine mandates especially when
Bill de Blasio goes on TV and says we're
going to tie your quality of life to the
Mandate your paycheck to the Mandate
there is going to be a dude I tell you
man that's what worries me they're going
to snap there's going to be a dude who's
like I don't want to do this I know
people who vote a Democrat who are
posting on Facebook smack talking me
laughing and gloating and I people I
know
then the Mandate started hitting for
their jobs and they're freaking out like
whoa whoa whoa like what is going on do
I really have to do this this freaking
me out these people are freaking out
when you mandate someone get a medical
procedure and get something put in their
body and they don't feel good about it
this is going to cause a psychotic break
in someone they are going to have a
mental breakdown they're going to drop
to their knees screaming freaking out
because you've backed them into a corner
too much
you cannot push people beyond their
reasonable boundaries for this long and
this far I used to work in non-profit
fundraising we would go up to people on
the street and tell them sign up for our
cause give us your money one of the
things I would talk to people about is
reasonable boundaries can you get a
person to do something that is
unreasonable the answer is no it's very
difficult it takes time and conditioning
after two years and a rapid Pace people
have now taken three shots many of these
people don't get their flu shots they've
not gotten their booster shots they live
their life and they mind their own
business but now they're in a position
where the government is beating them
down over and over and over again what's
happening this woman on the airplane she
snapped she lost it she saw someone who
is not experiencing the pain she
experiences when the government forced
her to do this and she was angry why
aren't you suffering like me and so she
spits in his mouth she walks up and
she's spit in his mouth well he had his
mouth open and she spit into his face
that's a good aim right into his like I
went pretty close yeah yeah and she was
very close but I think this is people
who are feeling anxiety and stress from
the government forcing to do things they
don't have the courage to say no and so
when they see someone who says no they
get angry because that's a reflection on
them yeah you're too weak they're not so
they say if I have to suffer you have to
suffer with me Bertrand Russell once
said quote Collective fear stimulates
herd Instinct and tends to produce
ferocity towards those who are not
regarded as members of the herd so that
quote is very fitting to a lot of what's
happening right now sociologically but I
I think a lot of people are just in this
constant state of anxiety paranoia fear
of this larger unknown and and I think a
lot of you know people out there play on
this fear of the unknown because it
works on our imagination it works on our
greatest fears personally in our lives
and I think a lot of of this has been
codified by a lot of the corporate media
coverage when you see what they're
saying when you see over and over again
the messaging that they're bringing out
there it's comply get on your knees do
as you're told or else the worst is
going to happen to you and that's a
message that is absolutely ridiculous
and absolutely one that not only induces
fear but destroys people's immune
systems at the same time let's talk
about this Trope where you get a a grade
school bully and he's beaten up the
young nerdy kid and then the nerdy kid
you know he's walking one day and then
he you know he's outside of school and
he sees the bully and there's his dad
bullying him you've seen this Trope
right the kid who's the bully is getting
bullied and because he can't stand up to
his dad he takes his anger out on other
people and makes him feel better about
himself that's what I think we're seeing
with people like this and all these
other videos it's people who are who
feel powerless who want to feel that
power so what do they do they join the
mob they grab a pitchfork and they
threaten and scream at you because it
makes it feel like they're in control
yeah and that I think both of our
theories are correct yeah I think you
have powerless and you have people are
at a breaking point but you also have
the just a bad combination of 80 year
old guy and if you've ever talked to an
80 year old man they just don't care
yeah like no don't tell I'm 80 years old
you know with this woman who's obviously
over the top power hungry telling them
what to do you had two people who are
not going to compromise you had Israel
versus Iraq you know what I mean like
you had no compromise right there so
here we go this dude's sitting in his
chair minding his own business and he's
eating he's literally following the
guidelines because look I'll tell you
what like on planes I don't know this
was a Delta flight but on United they
say you have to take your man you have
to wear your mask between bites uh they
say that but I guess that if you're
flying first class they give you more
leeway it's total classism
on the way back from um Arizona
um from my bodybuilding show the woman
next to me didn't have her mask on the
whole flight no drink no nothing I was
like well this is great so I took mine
off so I think that they do treat the
glasses differently
um but nonetheless nobody look man when
I have food or beverage in front of me
and I fly a lot my mask is off because
I'm not putting on my chin because what
if I dribble food like that's just nasty
and I'll be like look lady like if I
like dribble like there's food in this
mask I ain't got that many of them so I
I don't know I think it's just a
horrible combination and United
I've heard some bad horror stories
American's been really great but United
was fine today they didn't do anything
crazy they're all scared at the end at
the end of this the fact remains if
you're rich you're exempt yeah basically
you get a private jet well there's also
CEOs of American Airlines and Southwest
that are requesting that we get rid of
the masks on plane mandates and they're
saying this is you know this is
ridiculous and they're making arguments
against the federal policy for masks on
planes I I think some I think people are
going to lose their minds I think have
you seen these photos and videos of
people at Christmas in like what they're
called isolation bubbles oh yeah oh my
God this is happening
like Bubble Boy so there's like a woman
and they they built a frame out of PVC
pipe and then wrapped it in plastic wrap
and she's sitting in it and they're like
we're safe dude
people are going to lose their people
are losing their mind that that is
losing their minds Tim yeah you can buy
those plastic tanning like containers or
whatever it's like a wire frame it's
kind of like a hamper but it's bigger
and you zip it open and stand inside and
spray tan and it contains everything for
you oh I know there's a woman's there's
a woman sitting in one of those and she
like gives a thumbs up to the camera and
it's like you have lost your minds look
if you think you're sick you don't go to
a family gathering it's just that simple
like I I've had many family gatherings
where it's like oh yeah uh Joe can't
call me he came down with the flu it's
like okay
but these people are living in this
world where some of them aren't even
sick there's one guy and they were like
he had he had a potential close contact
so he's staying outside he had a van
opened up the back pulled up to the
window and he's sitting in his van
eating so that he could be there and I'm
like this is crazy your people are
losing their minds but what happens when
it's not just that people you know these
people have adopted this world view
they're choosing this and they're
smiling as they do it now there are
people like this lady they're not
smiling as they do it they're freaking
out like I think we're going to see
someone lose their mind and seriously
hurt themselves or others because
they're gonna just be like I'm over this
there's already been a lot of suicide
what happens what happens when someone
snaps
remember that term going postal back in
the day yeah when you worked in the post
office they drove you to the brink
because they were such bad employers
we're basically going to see a bunch of
people quote unquote go postal and it
makes you kind of empathy for the people
who are kind of losing their minds
because they went along with it now I'm
fortunate I live in Tennessee like we
literally did 15 days where I live we're
like okay that's enough we didn't die
cool let's go yeah I mean we were having
in July of 2020 in our gym we had a
shoulder to shoulder packed event
and nobody cared and the cops were there
having fun with us like it was a good
time whereas I watch for me to travel
and to watch the news is like watching
some weird like movie because none of
that ish happens where I live none of it
happens in in Williamson County
Tennessee we'll see a little glimpse of
it we'll see an occasional weirdo but at
the end of the day man we're just we
have wrestling tournaments it's packed
out here at the casino you can still
smoke indoors people are smoking all
over the place it's like it's the 1990s
there's no there's no when uh when all
this was first starting you'd go there
and they had plastic put up at every
table game and it was it was really
weird the funny thing is apparently with
the dividers up people were betting on
the don't pass line so for those aren't
familiar with craps oh my God are you
familiar with craps yeah so uh typically
people abandon What's called the pass
line you're betting for the guy who's
rolling the person rolling the die to
win but the don't pass line betting on
them to lose is a slightly better bet
typically people don't do that because
it's kind of a dick move but when the
dividers went up people were like I
don't care like you're separated from me
you can get mad like people just didn't
care it was a weird thing it really
really separated us but now out here
it's all over it's been over for a long
time there's there's there's no mandates
but there are still businesses because
we're close to DC that are engaging in
this you can tell they're more
left-leaning you go you go into West
Virginia and people are gonna be like
huh like it doesn't exist you know
people are just doing their thing a lot
of people have characterized it as
sanitation theater as there is some
preliminary data showing that it was
absolutely almost pointless when it
comes to quote stopping the spread and
again there's not a lot of science here
there's not a lot of data why aren't we
collecting the data why aren't we
investigating a lot of this
it's it's hard to navigate that space
but don't take it from Luke take it from
Joe Biden oh who said there's no federal
solution to the covid-19 pandemic that
means every bit of guidance you you
really got to understand what Joe Biden
said when he made the statement there's
no federal solution to coven that means
everything fauci said has been what
a lie a waste of our time yeah what do
you mean there's no federal solution Joe
no no no no no hold on people need to
understand a lot of people are like Joe
Biden's giving up a lot of people are
saying he's coming to to realize
whatever it is that statement is Joe
Biden undermining the entire Federal
response if there's no solution at the
federal level what have we been doing
the states have been taking guidance
from you from fauci you take a look at
what Andrew Cuomo said when he killed
all those people in the nursing home he
said we were getting Federal guidance
our is Joe Biden now coming out and
saying everything they did was not in
the effort to produce a solution to this
then what are they doing and why is
fauci still talking fire the guy Joe
Biden if there's no federal solution
then what is fauci doing the airlines
okay no more restrictions on airlines
you can have your New Year New Year's
parties because we can't do any of it
it's got to be the states
this is this is this is much bigger than
I think people realize what Joe Biden
said this is enormous I actually learned
about this today I'm like whoa because
you know we're just we're in the Green
Room doing our thing hanging out and I'm
like this is huge yeah like this is
literally 10th Amendment stuff man like
since when do Democrats care about the
10th Amendment let me let me let me read
some of this okay but I didn't have the
phone conference the nation's Governor's
Mondays covet cases began to rise when
speaking to Arkansas governor Aza
Hutchinson Biden said there's no federal
solution quote one word of cons one word
of concern or encouragement for your
team is that as you look towards federal
solutions that will help alleviate the
challenge make sure that we do not let
Federal Solutions stand in the way of
State Solutions the production of 500
million rapid tests that will be
distributed by the federal government is
great but obviously that dries up the
supply chain for the solutions that we
might offer as Governor there is no
federal solution this gets solved at the
state level Biden responded so that was
ASA Biden responded there is no federal
solution okay the president of the
United States has said everything that
they've done was not heading in the
direction of a solution it was not
solution oriented then why are we doing
it
literally ran on the platform of ending
coven yeah that was literally his thing
I will end kovid and instead we get more
covid we get more people who've had the
procedure getting coven it didn't stop
the transmission I think we have record
case New York City accounts didn't New
York City I think I read this 25 of the
positive covet cases are New York City
one of the most vaccinated places in the
country I believe that's 25 let's look
it up I think it's 25. if I'm mistaken
then I'm gonna blame it on someone else
okay well New York is breaking records
they're seeing uh uh nearly uh I don't
know about that that 25 statistic but
New York City is breaking records with
massive amounts of cases so I'll put it
this way I want to make sure I can say
something
thank you Joe Budden you are correct
yeah the solution here has always been
state level the federal guidance is
proving to be inadequate and Joe Biden
has correctly pointed it out and it was
the right thing to do and I'm glad he
did because now we can take a look at
Florida now Florida is doing fantastic
at the state level they have rejected
early this year I pointed out that Joe
Biden came out and said we may need more
lockdowns X Y and Z and all the things
you want to do and I was like he's not
talking to Red States he's talking to
Blue States because the red states are
not listening to him and you know what
Florida has been way better off for it
you look at the Gulf States and for some
reason they have these areas that are
doing really really well I wonder why
that is well so long as they're able as
states to handle their own issues it
seems to be working out and the big blue
states that are just following federal
guidelines executed a bunch of old
people in nursing homes because they
were like we're following federal
guidelines well that was under Trump
sure but it was the governors who did it
if Joe Biden is going to come out right
now and say the fact there's no federal
solution
okay then fauci can say whatever he
wants but it seems to be meaningless
it's going to have to be state level
it's going to be localized it took him
long enough and he sore did a lot of
damage and and it seems like almost
every action he committed he made the
situation that much worse I just posted
a meme of of The Simpsons and it's the
classroom where it's where it's the all
the students looking back at this one
one kid and says save the line and then
Biden is in the middle and he's like
covet is a state issue and everyone's
celebrating and cheering it and then
this is this is the moment that we
reached that we finally have this
Crescendo of the state realizing its
ineptness it's its inability to to take
care of the situation and at least it
has the the ability to see that it took
a very long time there's a lot of damage
done to the average American but it
should have always been a state issue
because States based on their
populations based on their circumstances
know what's right for their constituents
a lot more than a centralized top-down
Federal force that again Boggle build
this response from the very beginning
and can't even get testing right botched
yes
just really like being told what to do
let's New York loves that stuff let's
pull up pull it a fact this is the Joe
Biden promise fact checker and one of
his first promises get covid-19 under
control according to PolitiFact the
Biden promise tracker says this one is
in the works
Joe Biden quote I'm never going to raise
the white flag and surrender we're gonna
beat this virus we're gonna get it under
control I promise you okay PolitiFact
you need to go into your Biden promise
tracker and where it says in the works
put surrendered or failed whatever if
Joe Biden's promise was to get covered
under control but his response now to
Governor says hey don't look at us you
guys got to solve this problem
you can call it a white flag I think
it's a fair point Joe Biden said he
wouldn't raise it but he's certainly
raising it right now you're absolutely
correct I mean look you you can't go and
say that we need to do things federally
we need to get everybody to do this that
and the third and then all of a sudden
be like ah no no this has always been a
state's issue but all we've heard is
like he's Federal mandates the data and
he goes
oh we screwed up really no no I can't
say that he's sitting in his room and
he's like listen we're working hard on
this one at the federal level to get
things done oh Mr Biden uh president
here's your updated numbers and and
we're gonna fight hard to
it's a state's issue
um after reviewing the data uh I've
always said it was a state's issue look
man if he's now admitting the right
thing I'm glad he's doing it but it is
this is indicative of a bigger problem
here in this country that people voted
for a corporeal form that's what the
Atlantic said they didn't vote for a man
who's going to lead they voted for a man
who was not Trump that's it they put him
put him in his little wheelchair put the
blanket look I gotta I gotta bring it up
I gotta say it Joe Biden said let's go
Brandon Joe Biden himself let's go
Brandon he is so out of it he has no
idea what's going on that people are
literally chanting let's go let's go
Brandon they say let's go buddy let's go
Brandon let's go Brandon and Joe Biden
doesn't know
that's how clueless he is how do you not
know I literally have a Christmas
ornament that says let's go Brandon
it's pretty cool my neighbor gave it to
me look Joe Biden is so out of it and
not paying attention he did not know
that at stadiums across the country
people were chanting let's go Brandon
that there's merchandise you'd think
someone would have briefed him on this
like hey you need to know this is
instead he gets a phone call and the
guy's like Merry Christmas and let's go
Brandon he goes yeah I agree let's go
Brandon it's like wow maybe he did no
but he forgot like the guy is like 800
years old the emperor has no clothes
he's got dementia he's got Alzheimer's
he's got every disease you could get
above 80. like first of all why do we
have someone that damn old in office
second of all like he's not aging well
like look man I'm not a truck guy I'm
not I'm again like you I I like him for
some reason I voted for Trump but like
Trump is a really really vibrant and
healthy 70 plus year old right I don't
even the dude got younger since he's
been in office I know he's been losing
weight he looks great Biden is like we
Weekend at Bernie's like he's The
Walking Dead well I
I'll put it this way yes Trump during
his presidency he was an overweight man
he was not he was not a Bastion of
Health he he he loves McDonald's but
wasn't he he was on a bunch of
medications or if he's an older guy too
but his mind was at least still Trump
Joe Biden is the true nanashaba
depressure President we don't know what
that was or why or about a cathcare
I'm sorry one thing that really gets
better everything Biden does is that he
may as well just be saying those words
over and over again how can we trust him
when he comes out and says it's not a
federal issue what if he meant something
else in fact I'll give you a really good
example it was at I think a un meeting
he kept referring to Syria as Libya now
how do we know that honestly we don't
journalists just told us he met Syria
now here's the problem
Joe Biden speaking to a bunch of Nations
about conflict in the Middle East
let's say he genuinely meant to talk
about the conflict in Syria what if
there's someone who's there who doesn't
speak English and here's Joe Biden talk
and the translator says Joe Biden wants
military action in Libya they're gonna
go okay
how how are they supposed to know that
Joe Biden made a mistake and was talking
about something else is there translator
oh he said Libya but he met Sierra
they're gonna be like he said Libya what
are you talking about Joe Biden using
the wrong name of a country could you
imagine they're like we need to get a
military strike today unaware Libya okay
and they fire missiles and then he goes
like Oh I meant Syria worse still what
if Joe Biden did not mean Syria what if
he actually met Libya because his brain
is trapped in 2010 because he's old and
demented and so he's standing for the
U.N and other problems in Libya man yeah
there were problems in Libya with
Gaddafi and maybe Joe Biden can't
remember what's going on and so he's
actually thinking about a problem that's
not currently happening I mean Libya's
got its problems the fact is I don't
even know that Joe Biden meant to say
the word Federal and if these things
keep happening how can we trust a word
out of his damn mouth he could come out
and be like we gotta uh we gotta cure we
gotta fight uh kovid and he actually
meant to say fight for coven he's
actually in on the side of the virus I
have no idea what the government has
been doing there's an argument to make
there and when he would have bombed
Libya the media would have been like Joe
Biden and slavery in Africa bravely
committing an act against the slave
trade that was created there with the
vacuum of power that was created by our
first bombs now we've got more bombs
there you know you know it would have
been funny if uh when Joe Biden was
giving the speech and they the media
translates for him and they're like he
meant to say Syria okay sure maybe he
did but if he accidentally says Libya
and that resulted in an accidental
airstrike on um he accidentally says
Libya and it resulted in accidental
airstrike on Libya then the media is
going to be like this is a good thing it
doesn't matter whether it was the right
country or not they're going to be like
Joe Biden made it very Fierce they would
they would they would find a way to
argue that Joe Biden was doing this on
purpose he wasn't in fact A demented and
firing this with the wrong country they
would say something like Joe Biden had
been secretly planning for months now a
strike on militia forces in Libya and
the slave trade so here's a question
real quick so Trump's out of office
obviously the media hated Trump why is
the media still so
protective of President Biden it's
tribalism okay pure tribalism I I think
people need to understand that there's
there is an element of propaganda to it
there's some viral article going around
about some leftist YouTuber actually
being like funded by British
intelligence or something yeah sure
these are these things exist of course
they do there's information Warfare but
for the most part take a look at uh uh
you know Brian stelter on CNN count how
many times he criticizes Rachel Maddow
for being wrong I can't he blocked me oh
yeah it's a shame I I made fun of his
weight ah well he's really fast look he
is but uh I I like to keep it to the
keep to the ideas right yeah and if his
idea of a good show is to be like Fox
News is bad but literally never complain
well I should say figuratively never
complain about MSNBC or Rachel Maddow
then he's not a real journalist he's
just this is this is the look we can
come on this show
over and over again and be like here are
the things we don't like about Trump
hear the things we like about Trump also
Joe Biden's crazy and they act like
that's a hyper partisan show that's like
grifting or whatever and I'm like dude
Brian Selter CNN MSNBC they literally
lie to your faces we aren't Fox News
we're not we're not we're not repeating
Hannity's lines here we we have we have
arguments about this stuff
but I don't think they can handle those
kinds of these kinds of conversations it
has to be it has to be completely tribal
CNN built up an anti-trump audience if
they come out now it's called audience
capture and they say actually Trump did
well in these areas Their audience would
Revolt if they come out now and
criticize Rachel Maddow Their audience
would Revolt so they don't do it that's
it that's the demise of their Network so
you know it's too bad it's too bad I
mean that sarcastically it's too bad but
it you know I I wish we had better media
I think these developments proved my
earlier hypotheses that the president is
a puppet that there's multinational
corporations and powerful people behind
him especially at the Helms of power
that truly do pull the strings that do
set the policies and I think they're
using his presidency as a lame duck
presidency in order to jam through some
of the most unpopular craziest insane
policies that violate people's human
rights that destroy their ability to
have any Financial Mobility they're
using him as this kind of Trojan Horse
this docile old sleeping man and they're
ramming through some of the top-notch
globalist insanity that that no one
would ever want but but to me he's the
perfect cover and an excuse to do that
and I think because again he's clearly
not there who else is there I believe
the special interest those special
interests I think are there no matter
who is president and I think that a lot
of them do call the shots with a lot of
the unpopular policies that are passed
they're going to update this PolitiFact
fact Checker and like Biden's promise
tracker and they're gonna say promise
accomplished like he met he got covered
under control and that's why he's saying
there's no federal solution because he's
already got under control and now he's
just talking about other stuff as
unrelated to getting under control
because you know he's done well this is
going to be interesting because I think
in a few weeks he's going to be claiming
that he's the Victor he took down covid
because a lot of people now when they're
getting this new omnicron variant a lot
of people are building up immunity a lot
of people are getting this sickness so
there is a possibility here According to
some medical professionals that this
this could be the end of covet with how
virulent this virus is and how less
lethal it is compared to other variants
and for a lot of people this is the best
case scenario because this signals the
end of all of this I have to disagree
with you man I had a runny nose once
thing annoyed me yo have you ever seen
this video where they simulate a runny
nose with like UV ink or whatever
and so they have a party everyone plays
games and they have a very light runny
nose and it's ink and then at the end of
the of like the party they put a black
light on this they show this is crazy I
can't remember where I saw this you many
of you probably have seen the video it's
like you see him wipe his nose with the
kleenex and they show the black light
you can see the the ink coming out and
then at the end of the day you can see
the whole room is just covered in the
ink because people would be touching
everything it's really crazy man look I
got no problem saying if you're sick
don't come to my parties look man I'm
sorry you can't calm but don't get
people sick don't do that stuff when
your sick stay home like yeah my
daughter had a wrestling meet she had a
a little like stuffy nose I'm like
you're gonna be like grappling with
people yeah I don't take the day off day
off go watch some Netflix yeah just
chill I mean that's the problem I mean
chill when we were sick as a kid we
stayed home from school
we stayed home that's the answer we got
it we got it we got to talk about the
news you can use man this is really
gonna affect you guys fauci he wants to
uh he says no parties no parties you
can't do New Year's Eve parties I'll
tell you what I'm having a New Year's
Eve party yes well we're gonna we're
gonna grab some steak we're gonna have
some Trump champagne and then we're
gonna go hit the casino because they're
doing a big countdown and they got the
new Barstool Sports thing I think is
officially open oh sweet awesome it
looks so amazing they got wings and beer
it is gonna be so much fun but Airbnb
vows to crack down on New Year's Eve
parties quote as we build upon the party
ban and continue to protect our
community during this unprecedented time
certain holidays such as New Year's Eve
attract higher risks of unauthorized or
disruptive parties that's why we're
introducing new products and policies to
crack down on disruptive New Year's Eve
parties helping to protect our hosts and
minimizing is a ban on one night Nye
bookings an entire home listings for
guests with a history of positive
reviews all right well
Airbnb no parties here here's the
original parties there's verbo go
somewhere else you know we have verbo
it's a great little process here if you
don't like what Airbnb is doing so is
this all in the name of covet or is just
this just to avoid messing up
neighborhoods I think it's it's to avoid
messing up people's homes because when
you have parties at people's homes I
mean you obviously destroy the property
that that people rent and this could be
the major factor in there because you
know if I'm renting a property to
someone it's for them to use it like a
hotel not like a club yeah so covid I
think could be the scapegoat because as
someone who's looking into some some
property in Vegas for example
um yeah I'd want to stay away for I'd
actually block that night out so I think
it's a way for them to protect their
properties if I look at it this way I
think Cove is just the scapegoat as it
is with every customer service issue
I've ever had since 2020. hey man um I
got this shirt and it's missing two
buttons well you know covid
how the hell is that covet you know it's
at the end everything man I think it
could be a scapegoat we we got a super
chat from someone you know I see it in
passing where they mentioned as an as a
flight attendant
they were saying most people you know
don't have covid but they're reporting
the reason all the flights are getting
shut down and canceled is because people
are calling in sick with covid due to
the surge
sounds like at least from this one
employee in there in their bubble it's
people just calling out using covet as
an excuse they said when we claim we're
sick with covet we don't get in trouble
really there's a there's a meme going
around showing a test and someone
drawing in the line saying this is how I
make sure I don't work on New Year's Eve
um and there might be some of that there
might be people faking their tests or
just saying hey I'm sick here because
they don't feel like working as of
course that's been the overall trend for
this year a lot of people saying I just
don't want to work I don't want to work
for a company and and make dollars that
are going to be absolutely worthless as
their value keeps declining almost every
single day I I see all these photos and
videos of democrats for the most part
not wearing masks now look there are
Republicans who don't wear masks too but
they're the ones who come out ragging on
masks and mask mandates so I'm like okay
well that's in line with what they've
been saying when you see these Democrats
come out like Whitmer like Newsome like
Pelosi like even faucet that baseball
game where his mask turned down
and I'm like these are these are the
ones who are coming out claiming we need
this how much you want to bet they
didn't get vaccinated either you know
what joke I think that might be
vaccinated it's weird because that's
like me you know doing my whole health
and fitness ifbb Pro thing and coming
out and them having that remember that
video of Arnold like like topless and it
was really a mess it's like oh my god
what happened Arnold it's hypocrisy like
before before the show Mark was eating a
big thing of Nacho
cheesecake remember Winnie the Pooh with
the honey
I'm seeing that with my freaking Hands
by the way I would like to say I've gone
an hour without saying a curse word
um
you spent time with me today you know I
got it all out earlier well don't worry
in the members only segment you'll just
erupt and wait till you see my fans only
page Litany of curses hey you got to
make money man so let's do that yeah I
gotta make up for the Kroger thing so
I'm doing an only fans page tonight
please don't so what were we talking
we're talking about we're talking about
Airbnb cracking down and I said I think
Democrats are faking I'm lying about
getting vaccinated I absolutely think
there's a lot of people not getting it
who say they are getting it I know
personally people who have doctor
friends who give the injection to an
imaginary spot next to their shoulder I
know multiple people doing that look
when you start mandating things you get
people faking things when they don't
want it you get counterfeits and these
are real cards they're just not getting
the needle in the arm I just think if
there are Democrats who are going to go
on TV and be like everyone's got to wear
a mask and then they don't it's horrible
I also think the same kind of people are
gonna be like everyone's gotta get
vaccinated and then don't you know well
ethics and hypocrisy you can't once you
cross a certain ethical line you've
crossed that line so it becomes your
Norm so that's why you have to have
those those lines you don't cross so
once you start lying about one thing I
tell this to my kids all the time if
you're lying about masks you're doing
something else then you can think well I
can do this against this too yeah I
could do this about this too and that's
why I'm always one of those Practice
What You Preach if you don't believe it
don't say it kind of guys unfortunately
politicians are not the cream of the
crop you know what the cream of the crop
is us we're in the private sector we're
building businesses we're employing
people and we probably have higher than
average IQs the people in Washington DC
and politics they're complete morons
have you ever talked to these people
they're dumb have you seen this is
there's a DCS put out a tweet I don't
know if you guys saw it Oh yeah and it
said this is what DC will look like if
global warming stays on this path and it
showed DC flooded and my response was
I'm not sure if this is pro global
warming or anti-global warming yeah just
but I'll leave it there these people
aren't that's why I'm like when I see
these kids while they're Pelosi and
binaurkins I'm like dude these people
are dumb like they're not the smartest
people if you've ever seen the movie um
by Chris Bell bigger stronger faster
they literally there was a guy I think
his Waxman who is a senator or a
congressman in California who voted for
the steroid act whatever to to make them
illegal and they when they asked him
what steroids were or something and he
had no clue what he voted for let's talk
Second Amendment look into that oh God
so these people there are people who
read into it like empty Marjorie Taylor
green she she believes what she's saying
and she's well educated and versed on
what she's doing Thomas Massey that's
the guy right there Rand Paul as well
these are smart people but you look at a
lot of these people like they don't even
show up for votes they have that one MTG
called him out Margaret Taylor green
called him out we're my own senator from
uh Tennessee didn't show up to a vote on
justices I believe it was and it was
horrible and I'm like oh nobody from
Tennessee is going to be on that list
and then there was a Senator that I
really really like who knows your job is
to vote
you don't even work that much yeah go
vote how many months are they in session
it's like they're out most of the year
and then they show up for a little bit
it's disgusting it's disgusting the way
this has gone and and we just have a
bunch of weak people who are funded by a
bunch of really rich people making the
laws and people like us like I was
explaining earlier I'm not going to run
for office I can't handle that yeah
because I'll be punching people on the
floor and I will never make it past a
camp an election campaign I won't make
it I'm not built for that instead I'm
gonna affect the local level I'm gonna
coach kids but the smart people are out
there like Elon Musk you don't think
that man can run a country like he's
sending people to space he's building
generators like okay I think you need
decentralized power
I think you can make an electric car but
I don't know about telling people like
you know effective policy he's also
working under the Nancy Pelosi knowing
he could I mean look man my my
eight-year-old son can do better than
these idiots in office right now well
it's because they're self-interested yes
you know if you if you if you you could
take you know uh some local custodian as
long as he's interested in doing the
right thing for his neighbors in the
country he would do an infinitely better
job than any one of these politicians
absolutely correct you've got a you've
got a small handful out of you know the
hundreds of members of Congress a small
handful you like Rand Paul Thomas Massey
that like people who actually believe
what they're doing and looking at these
things and actually stand up most of
them it's really funny when I'm reading
about members of Congress and I'm like I
have no idea who that is it's like oh
someone's being criticized for not doing
their job like who are these people how
are they even on any party they don't do
anything uh sociopaths there's a reason
the the most amount of social sociopaths
per capita or in Washington DC and I
want to go back to your original kind of
Point here talking about how 25 of the
cases are from New York as according to
the latest Google statistics from
yesterday there was 54
828 cases uh coming from the state of
New York specifically in New York City
nationally there was 189
714 cases so that's about 25 percent
coming from New York City specifically
themselves according to the statistics
provided by Google nice
um so I I believe if it was Florida it
would have been a totally different
story if 25 of the cases came from
Florida the media would have been
talking about it obsessively but of
course
um they're not but again a lot of these
people who are calling the shots or
working with the politicians or working
with the corporate media and uh to me
there's there's more about pushing an
agenda pushing a narrative than the
truth and these people are not here to
serve you and and that's why it's it's
very easy to say that there anyone could
do a better job than they will be
because it's obviously true because when
you have someone who is there serving
the special interests they're of course
are doing everything not into to your
advantage so what they're doing is
deliberately trying to screw you over
and they are I love how Pelosi was like
we should be allowed to trade stocks you
know she just asked about it yeah yeah
they were like we should we should not
we should we should Block members of
Congress I'm you know buying and
training stocks like no we're private
individuals we can do this and it's like
okay so it's not a private individual so
they Public Service they know there's a
vote coming up the lobbyists come to
them and say hey if this bill passes bad
things will happen to this company and
she goes you know and then these
politicians can be like I'm gonna short
this company and then vote Yes and then
they make tons of money because they are
in control of it is corruption how are
these people so rich like Biden's worth
tens of millions of dollars it's not
from speaking engagements like how
that's the question you need to look at
like gee I wonder you need to look at
these people and they've been in like
he's been in off like I'm 40 life his
whole life 47 48 years
um Bernie Sanders didn't really have a
job till he was in his 40s he was my age
when he finally got a job what job
government yeah I'm pretty sure Bernie
never had a job outside of government so
so look at it this way they're getting
the money from somewhere and it's not
the 170k a year they're getting from us
so why are they multi-multi-multi multi
multi-millionaires and why aren't we mad
like why aren't we throwing chairs we
should be throwing chairs we should have
a national throwing chairs day and just
start throwing chairs because at this
point it's insane that nobody's mad why
am I the only one mad at this
I think a lot of people are just either
not paying attention or uh
they just think they're going to comply
their way out of this well a lot of
people believe the other side is is so
much worse you know picking between the
lesser of two evils people have been
convinced that their side is better when
in reality they're looking at Absolute
crap either way of the spectrum but look
look I see it all the time on Twitter
where these Democrats are like
Republicans did this or that in 2008 and
I'm like you really think Republicans
today have anything in common with
Republicans back then I mean there's
people like Mitch McConnell for sure but
everybody hates him you know so I I
think the problem is people who don't
read and people who do I should I should
say the tribes are you've got the
uninitiated people who live in in Wally
World on CNN and the people who actually
challenge the narrative in our reading
and trying to figure out what's really
going on yeah but let's jump to the
story my friends because none of it
matters it none of it matters
it's happening it's from the New York
Post NASA hired 24 theologians to study
human reaction to aliens
the official narrative I guess or
another official narrative but what
people are saying is basically that NASA
is trying to figure out how different
people of different Faith backgrounds
will react to the knowledge of
intelligent alien life in our uh
existing
the first thing I'll say is
it's strange to me that there are people
who believe aliens don't exist
in this massive of a universe as big as
it is
there's got to be life somewhere you
know what I mean now whether or not I
can travel the universe and come here
and interact with a different story
the New York Post reports Between Heaven
and Earth where do aliens fit in that's
the question NASA hopes theologians at
the center for a theological inquiry in
Princeton New Jersey can answer
University of Cambridge religious
scholar Reverend Dr Andrew Davison who
also holds a doctorate in Biochemistry
from Oxford as one of the 24 theologians
enlisted to help his upcoming book
astrobiology and Christian doctrine do
it due out in 2022 will cover in part of
the CTI and NASA's joint spiritual
exploration
there's a question is it really
happening you know who really looking
for aliens you know who really gets
Credit in all this scientologists
they've had this right all along they
believe that aliens came down and the
Church of Scientology wins oh yeah
there's aliens absolutely and um well
whether they came down or not but
literally like what was it in 2020
they're like the government's like dude
there's UFOs and we don't know what they
are yeah people are like meh and and the
only one I saw really getting uh like
through like if I was a kid like and you
told me that aliens and the Loch Ness
monster were real and Bigfoot I'd have
been I'd be running around the block
naked telling everybody about it right
like now it's like Joe Rogan was the
only one like dude there's aliens and
that was it and nobody cared well
there's absolutely alien or UFOs when
you have the government promoting the
idea of of aliens and Neil degrice Tyson
I just automatically think that they're
preparing for the next psyup I mean the
corporate media the government aliens
aliens aliens it used to be just people
outside of the box talking about this
but now it's the establishment saying
there's aliens out there there's
something out there that defies the laws
of science that buys the laws of physics
we don't know what it is
um that's absolutely mindfulness so is
Neil deGrasse Titan uh Tyson now a part
of the establishment I think so
absolutely he's completely changed his
tune from he's a g that dude's smart
yeah I think he's getting paid had have
you guys ever read Watchman the graphic
novel I have not so it's different from
the movie and the graphic novel is more
relevant in this Regard in uh in
Watchmen the bad guy simulates an alien
attack to force Global Unity because
it's the height of the Cold War and
Russia and the us are going to file
missiles at each other and nukes and so
he stages an alien invasion convinces
everybody we have to unify to fight
against it to stop War right
maybe that's the psya convince everybody
of the world that we need one world
government because of an alien invasion
you ever see uh Independence Day I was
just about to bring up I think they did
this movie The Will Smith before right
so Independence Day is all the different
countries are trying to they're all
independently fighting these aliens and
then they're like send out the word you
know here's how you take them out or
whatever we're gonna do a virus in the
sequel they did the whole planet is a
unified it's one world government
unified military Moon military base in
case the aliens come that I think is is
a lot of people thought covet would do
this that this this is you know a
universal threat would we unite
everybody I'm not convinced I think if
they actually did discover aliens the
left and the right would react and hate
each other over it and it would become
another tribal issue well we have to
explain why the government for decades
and decades was like aliens don't exist
you're crazy you're you're a conspiracy
theorist you're out of your mind if you
do and then they just officially changed
their stance like oh yeah they exist
they're out there why okay what was
behind this larger stance that that that
essentially was 180 degrees in the
opposite direction so obviously a lot of
people have those questions did you hear
Alex Jones recently when he went on that
he went on that rant and uh uh and like
I was like I can't do it anymore it's
like I'm gonna I'm gonna go to
pre-record and just leave and he was
saying he just started yelling and he
was like an alien intelligence that's
running this shot or whatever and I'm
like okay look you know part of his rent
was that he was mad people weren't
standing up to tyranny but then he
mentioned like alien intelligence
controlling everything and I'm like okay
now you lost me
yeah Alex Jones has a test
but like it's it's funny because then we
get the story about NASA hiring
theologians there's an episode of Star
Trek the Next Generation
where uh Picard and the Gen and the
Enterprise crew are making first Contact
in Star Trek the Next Generation the
Federation only contacts civilizations
once they discover warp technology
because it means they're about to start
traveling the stars and going other
planets and they'll soon be interacting
with life in the universe so they come
to this planet where they just invent
Warp and they're like you need to
consider what this will mean for your
people and your planet and the president
of the country they go to basically says
we're a deeply religious people this is
too much for us too soon people would
lose their minds if they discovered this
hence the New York Post talking about
theologians and needing to better
understand this because I think a lot of
people might lose their minds if aliens
were here then the assumption is aliens
are here they are involved and
everything that's happening is related
to some like alien contact or something
we just don't know it yet well here's
the thing the government can literally
say the opposite thing of what they said
yesterday and people believe it fousey
literally came out and said you don't
need to wear masks don't need to wear
them they just get dirty and then he's
like Schmutz we're like three of them
and people like yes science all the
government has to do is say aliens
science and people be like oh oh they
will forget people are dumb like the
Twitter generation I say this because
it's like there's no history like it's
the new cycle is like one minute people
have no short-term memory it's like they
smoke too much weed people are just they
don't remember anything and this is long
term like area fifth was area 5700 Heinz
57
it's delicious but anyways
about that whole alien thing like my
generation was all about aliens aliens
was my life like I'm like I read books
on Aliens and I was like going to the
library remember libraries we had those
because I went to library I'd check out
these books on Aliens these kids don't
remember that like for example my
wrestling team were out of tournament
I'm like dude beat that kid up like Hulk
Hogan like who's Hulk and I'm like you
don't know how Cogan is they have no
idea about the alien stuff that went on
it'll be dudes like us who are too old
to care like I'm 41. I think a crazy 41
year old talking about aliens gonna get
anybody excited when they were talking
about UFOs and no one really cared I was
like that's kind of it right yeah
they're gonna keep trickling out stories
like this to desensitize people and then
in like two or three years if um if
there were really aliens I'm not saying
there are that they'll have to slow roll
it and then eventually one day they'll
be like oh we saw a spaceship no no no
no sorry sorry go ahead finish
eventually they'll be like hey this is B
warp he's really the one running they're
calling the shots here he was really
under President Biden's skin
to be like people was the greatest
president ever everyone agrees at least
that's what I was told if you don't
believe in aliens I just want you to
look up the name Lori Lightfoot
[Laughter]
wow that is a specimen right there right
there you look at what's going on and I
think a lot of people want to believe in
aliens because you look at the seemingly
coordinated effort that's been happening
around the country some people think
it's you know the Illuminati or whatever
but Alex Jones was yelling as like an
alien intelligence controlling all the
stuff and I'm like yeah I don't know
about any of that stuff because it would
mean that like Ron DeSantis isn't
working with the aliens or something so
there's no coordinated alien I don't
know man there's a lot that the
government knows that they're not
releasing that they're not getting out
there to the general public that still
is classified which is ridiculous I mean
we should at least know what's going on
but we should also be prepared for a
potential psyop and for them to
weaponize and use that information for
their own benefit and their larger
paragraphs it's a great distraction
right there's no evidence we've got
aliens coming to Earth we there's
there's various paradoxes a lot of
speculation about it but I think it's
it's funny to see these stories it's fun
to talk about absurdity at least at
least aliens are in the realm of
possibility unlike Don Lemon asking
about whether or not an airliner was
sucked into a black hole
could there be aliens yes astronomically
abysmal odds and anything like this is
ever you know I'll tell you what's
infinitely more infinitely more likely
is that the government needs
distractions yes they need the people to
get whipped up in a frenzy if aliens
ever came the first thing I think is
like is that a government projection of
our vehicle is it a drone are they just
trying to screw with us because I look
until I see beat board come out and then
walk up to me and go I'm gonna be like I
don't believe it I don't believe it I'll
never believe it
until I see borp himself yeah I'm a
whole nut hope man beat borp 20 24. uh
vote for him and I don't know if it
satisfied the lizard people I don't know
the aliens so the aliens working with
the lizard people that's the question
the aliens are the lizard people no no
the lizard people are from Hollow Earth
oh okay or something isn't that stranger
things I'm so confused
there's there's I I love these you know
deep dive Rabbit Hole websites I was
reading one that claims there was a very
intelligent species of dinosaur that
fled into caves when you know the the
extinction event happened and survived
and they've been evolving for you know
millions of years so they're
substantially more advanced than humans
and they're in underground cities and
there are people who believe that stuff
man they believe they're underground
cities of futuristic aliens you know I'm
sorry they're terrestrial but like
lizard people or whatever it's crazy
what was what was it oh yeah I was
watching The Simpsons there's a clip
when um Bob Dole and Bill Clinton are
king and kodos yeah and then Homer
Simpson's like your your politicians are
actually Green Space lizards and I was
like is that where the conspiracy came
from or were they making fun of the
conspiracy because it was like
pre-internet you know a long time ago a
long time ago like The Simpsons have
gotten more things correct oh yeah
that's true of all the things to get
right it's gonna turn out that our
politicians are actually alien lizards I
I'm not dude like here's the thing about
2020 and 2021 nothing surprises me
anymore like I used to be like I can't
believe that and I'm like yeah okay cool
it's Thursday you know he just you see
the most absurd things happen people say
the most absurd things and it just
happens and you're like oh it's just
normal now there's a super chat here by
Julie Simone that is uh relevant to the
argument we had about the yellow fever
single shot dose uh saying that
according to the CDC it is just a single
dose I went to a doctor
and he said it's a subcutaneous
injection and you have to come back
after six months and that if you get the
second shot after six months it provides
immunity for 10 years
that's what I was told when I went to
the doctor but not every six months
you get the shot then you come back for
a six a booster at six months and then
it's good for 10 years at least that's
what I was told yeah yeah uh let's go to
let's go to super chats if you haven't
already smash the like button subscribe
to the channel go to timcast.com become
a member because at 11 PM at timcast.com
we're gonna have that members only
segment Laden with profanity a lot of
profanity I've been holding on here it
is oh it is bubbling to the top it is
just like a volcano ready to erupt of
f-bombs and s-bombs and I might even
drop a few C bombs you guys got to join
us cue bombs and R bombs and a bombs I'm
gonna make up words
all right no dice says you've got some
sick gains man well I think they're
talking to you Tim no I'm not talking to
me
I I I always skip arm day I'm I only
skate so it's all Leg Day oh well that's
fine dude you're the opposite of
everybody it's true yeah that's the
funny thing about uh people who skate is
they have like all the muscle mass on
their lower body and none upper body so
the center of gravity is a lot lower
which is interesting because skating
requires you want to keep percent of
gravity low for balance and stuff I just
thought that was funny it's like
everybody does their arms they skip leg
day I actually trained legs right when I
landed today and um man it was it's just
like at 41 you don't just get off the
plane and train and I I can know better
than that
about my age today all right we got
Samuel here he says I miss Ian it's not
the same without him still a great
episode love you guys and hope everyone
had a good Christmas I had a great
Christmas how was your guys Christmas
good really awesome oh my God best
Christmas ever I went to uh um I went to
a house at a Christmas party and they
had a plate full of jalapeno poppers it
was jalapenos sliced in half filled with
cheese and wrapped in bacon I ate eight
of them this is so good I couldn't stop
it's just so too it's too good two good
poppers we did um on Christmas uh Eve it
was actually we celebrated we did uh we
went bowling it was so much it was so
much fun because there's this place
Kings Bowl in Franklin Tennessee and it
was just they have music they had this
like cool techno like Christmas music
and I really like my kids so we had a
good time I never get to spend time with
like all of them it's always like one
going to a soccer tournament here or
there and it was just good to spend time
with my family and put my phone away
yeah yeah right
Kyle Miller says Tim just a reminder
that Trump Towers in NYC and Chicago
were used in the filming of the best
Batman film The Dark Knight yes and uh
Lower Wacker they called it lower fifth
in the movie uh I was staying at Trump
Tower because I had to yeah he's like
you got it if I'm gonna they've got
hotels all over but I'm like no I don't
know about Trump right I want to go
there and I want to see what's cracked
up to be and uh Sheamus was hanging out
with us because he was in Chicago with
his family and he was like we walk in
you know I can't come over we're gonna
hang out and he says can I have these M
M's the mini bar I'm like yeah sure and
he opens up the box inside the silver
box was just a regular bag of M M's to
which he then eats and then I checked
the pricing and it was seven dollars wow
now look look a lot of people a lot of
people were like Jim that's normal for
mini bars oh hold on
I have been to many different hotels in
my days and I will tell you this most of
the ones I've been to and I've been to
like the Intercontinental in the Four
Seasons and things like that they will
have M MS but they won't be called M Ms
they'll be called like Madam uh Palm
fries magical chocolate Delights and
it'll be like in a little glass jar
wrapped in a bow and it'll come from a
local confectionery or something like
that
yes there are places you go where it's
like the mini bars the Snickers and M Ms
but they're not seven dollars Trump once
again screwing over the American people
for the benefit of the multinational
corporation no I felt like it was
perfectly Trump well I mean it was like
I'm quite trash to stay at those kind of
hotels where I'm from we get free water
because we're frequent stayers oh yeah
shout out to Hilton and uh yeah they
give you free water you get to choose
one of like five snacks you get the beef
jerky stuff they give you the mini bar a
bottle of trump wine uh Cabernet
Sauvignon
and uh from Trump Winery and we decided
to bring it to one of the family
gatherings to and it was a hit everybody
loved it no joke I didn't even get to
try it because they cracked it open and
everybody just went nuts and just like
they annihilated that Trump wine and I
was like wow must be good I need some
trouble oh but then I I did get to try
when we went back they had more and I
was like I gotta try this people really
loved the Trump wine here's the thing I
was like
if I bring this to a family gathering
are they going to get angry are they
going to laugh because those are the two
outcomes there is no circumstance in my
opinion in which someone goes wow a
trump this is going to be fit everybody
laughed and they were like oh you're
bringing a trump wine and it was funny
and it was silly and then they really
really liked it but there was no person
who was like oh I'm impressed wow a
trump 2018. this is amazing no I just
thought it was funny nobody nobody got
mad about it but there were some people
who are like I think some people might
get offended you know you got to watch
out it's family time and get offended by
wine
anti-trump never Trump or people are
gonna be like what are you doing you
know I just like Biden if you bought me
some Biden wine I'd be like cool why
yeah you know I do think most people
regardless of the left or right would
have a sense of humor about it but you
never know some people yeah they get
triggered man just cause says toss away
authoritarianism like it's a seven
dollar bag of M M's I made a video where
I opened the box and I'm like it's a bag
of M M's and then I throw it and someone
commented Yeet and all caps they were
they I guess they really liked the video
I just threw it on the ground I was like
ah seven dollar M M's we did not eat the
second bag but I'm actually probably
charged to charge us anyway
Let's see we got Kyle Ellis says Tim
people in Chicago don't care about mask
mandates because Chicago was clearly
Maga country
yep
that's the crazy thing though I mean
obviously it's not Maga country but
people there were just not having it
yeah it's funny when you go into places
and some people just do it and some
people don't but when I walked into I
walked into the hotel and it's like
there's a big sign saying like you have
to wear a mask and first of all I'm like
I don't have one I don't and they were
like well we can get you one and I was
like the elevator is right there the
amount of time it takes you to go and
get me the mask versus me walking to the
elevator I'm gonna beat you to the
elevator I'm gonna be in my room what
are we supposed to do seriously I don't
have one should I wait outside while you
go get it Nick I didn't there was no
speech like that it was just that's my
mentality I walk in and the guy's like
we can grab one I'm like I'm gonna walk
to the elevator and okay you want to do
that later but they like I came down the
front desk had him I kept them in my
pocket no one said anything to me though
there were some circumstances where I
wore it because I don't think it's that
big of a deal you know but the problem I
have with it is the logic it's like walk
into a restaurant for literally five
seconds I'm not even exaggerating five
seconds I open the door and there's a
table 10 feet away and I go one one
thousand two and I sit down and take it
off I'm like why did that happen
well logic and science obviously don't
mix
science
that's all you have to say all right and
Arizona says during small talk with a
co-worker today she mentioned that her
sister wouldn't come to dinner with
anyone who was unvaxed my co-worker said
we'll never go back to normal people are
demoralized and that's why I say Civil
War so often yeah well I've heard the
term National divorce I don't know how
that worked logistically and I've I've
heard you explain your side of it and
uh honestly I think we already kind of
have a national divorce you have people
moving from Blue states to Red States
and these are these are just more more
freedom minded individuals so the
ideological polarization is becoming
geographical polarization yes that
precipitates Civil War yeah you're right
it's funny man because I keep saying
stuff like this and everything there are
people who get mad about it and then
it's like okay after the Chas after the
George Floyd riots after the George
Floyd autonomous Zone after January 6.
like how much more do people need to be
like this country's on the verge of
falling apart and then you get Bill
Maher who's like but the Mason-Dixon
Line would go through Nana's Kitchen
because the point he's trying to make is
that our ideological split is internal
with our families now you have this
graph showing California Illinois and
New York with a mass Exodus to Florida
Texas and other similar States and that
is the ideological polarization of
Nana's Kitchen turning into geographical
polarization which deepens the
ideological polarization because the
echo Chambers are becoming more intense
and when they do people start becoming
much much more tribal and angry and then
there is a gap that cannot be bridged it
is happening maybe maybe it all ends
right now well and the proud Boy and
Ricky tario walks up to the leader of an
antifa whoever that would be and they
shake hands and they hug and they cry
and say it's time to stop fighting we
now are coming together for the sake of
America is that going to happen are the
proud goal is going to walk up to
anti-fun shake hands and and sing and
hold hold hands on a rainbow it's the
opposite I got people on social media
dming me because I obviously took a
stand against something saying that you
know their uncle or their Grandma won't
let them come over because they're not
vaccinated so you got people who might
dude I mean you might have I mean are
vaccinated well if you're yeah if you're
not if you're if you're not vaccinated
you cannot go there okay so you know we
have a situation where you might have
families to be like screw it I'm gonna
take out grandma
oh man I hope it doesn't come to any of
that stuff oh no I'm definitely hoping
it doesn't but people people in their
own families are fighting with each
other they're hating each other they're
disowning each other it's it's it's
unlike anything I think I'd ever see or
something as stupid as this but here we
are it's look the example I'd like to
bring up is when I went to the peace
wall in Belfast in Northern Ireland and
you're familiar with the troubles in
Northern Ireland oh yeah I've been going
on since it's it's it's but it's toned
down quite a bit oh a lot but on one
side of the wall it's pro-israel on the
other side it's pro-palestine and for
seemingly no reason like why do the
people of the you know Northern Ireland
have a concern about the plight of
Israel because one side adopted one
issue and the other side took the
opposite stance that's what's happening
in the U.S like we have already the
rugged Man on the show and I and I
literally say to him I agree with you
about racism I myself have been a victim
and his response is to insult me and and
to ride me and then go on The Young
Turks and they do the same thing quite
literally me saying I agree with you on
these problems of systemic racism and I
understand a little bit of it turns into
a tribal mockery because it doesn't
matter what the issue is this is this is
the challenge I say why I don't think
there's a way out of this if there are
many people on the right who are who
constantly constantly Ben Shapiro comes
out everybody you know the vaccines are
great and they're safe and effective
Venture Bureau says it they mock him
they insult him and they call him an
anti-vaxxer Donald Trump comes out in an
interview with Candice Owens and says
the vaccine's great it's a huge
accomplishment everyone should get it
and then the left acts like it's the
first time Trump ever said this
yo if there are people who are
constantly trying to reach on an olive
branch and the other side is swatting it
away over and over again I don't see a
path out of here let's let's read
something with you all right the meaning
of nerd says hey Tim I'm the guy who
asked if I could use your song and make
a philosophical analysis on it I wanted
to let you know that I made the video
now and I'm really proud of it it's a
short video so I would love it if you
would check it out just search the
philosophy of Tim pool's will of the
people I will check it out he's ready
I am writing it down as we speak
confirmed he's writing it down yep I
will check it out all right
let's see what we got here JN says when
has government kingdoms relinquished or
rolled back power
Tim you got discernment read Mark 24 and
Thessalonian in Revelations all books in
the Bible the book is future proof
yeah there's nothing more permanent than
a temporary government program or policy
well was it isn't the stuff you go
through at the airport wasn't that
supposed to be temporary yeah thing yeah
because I'm actually maybe I'm
conditioned to it but
you know with pre-check and everything
yeah it's it's not terrible it's not
like like back in the 80s and 90s you
could actually walk with your child to
the gate yeah hold their hand as they
walk onto the plane or wait for your
family to get off yeah yeah all right
let's see
Quagmire's uh quag Quagsire Esquire says
Mark is the goat he put his money where
his mouth was and made a stand on
principle where can I buy your product
now so I need to support you
um tigerfitness.com
t-i-g-e-rfitness.com is a great place
also any local vitamin shop HyVee HEB we
have a lot of great partners for New
York Natural Body everybody nutrition we
got a lot of amazing retailers out there
so many good retailers right on Rancor
says he said mandatory morning
calisthenics I thought of 1984 dude
doing his mandatory morning exercises
where big brother could see Good Times
that's that's the joke yes the idea is
how many lives would be saved if every
person in order to get access if you
want to go to a diner you had a nap you
wake up in the morning or any point of
the day you have to do 30 minutes of
calisthenics and when you do your phone
knows it tracks it and then says you've
unlocked eating outside and going to the
movies wouldn't that make sense the same
as these vaccine mandates if it saves
one life that's right that's right yeah
we don't do that we can't do that well
Tim I just want to bring up that
covet is generally attacking people who
are obese and old well it's it's it's
more heavily impacting yes so here's the
thing it's attacking the weak obesity
makes you weak if we really cared we'd
do something about obesity this was the
greatest opportunity in American history
to get people wakened up to lose weight
and get into shape and better their odds
at not dying instead we locked them in
their house closed down gyms and
delivered beer to their house
how absurd is this so if we want to make
a difference
whether you're if you're not fit I want
you to get fit I want you eat better I
want you to exercise more I don't care
what you do for exercise CrossFit ballet
bodybuilding yoga I don't give a crap
what you do do that if you are in shape
I want you to find someone who's not in
shape and I want you to Mentor them and
I want you to work out with them and I
want you to help them we can end this
now we just need to get into Better
Health period that will make our society
much better
the PB Farm says
colors worth of outright bars I'm sick
of companies not taking a stand to
support those who will oh man I I love
you I really do
um what is 4 million divided by 90.
okay that's how many people to start
buying
thank you so much man appreciate it
you'll enjoy it trust me Richard says
Tim I have a flight attendant and almost
no one has Omicron we are simply tired
for two years of of what's going on and
we just want to be home for the holidays
we don't get in trouble for RONA call
outs God bless so that when when the
Southwest thing happened and everyone
said it was a work stoppage and like a
strike I spoke with a pilot who said
it's none of that there's no organized
effort nobody's up a phone call saying
everybody call in sick people just
calling in sick when they came out and
said mandates for vaccines people just
were like I'm gonna use as many sick
days as I have left
because they thought this was they were
going to lose their job so it wasn't
coordinated it's just what happened okay
it's coincidence that worked out for the
better I guess
all right you know who says was on
United first class on 12 24. stewardess
harassed me the second of my beer
touched the armrest to raise my mask I
was so confused I didn't even know she
was talking to me
man crazy I had no issues when I flew to
Austin no uh I nobody said anything to
me if my mask was down or up or whatever
like when I was eating food or like when
I get to the bathroom not a single word
from anybody see here's the thing um
have you looked at like maybe they just
don't like you like you got to be nice
to people like if I go out like you'll
notice I'm like yes sir yes ma'am I'm
I'm cordial because I genuinely like
people so if you come on the plane and
you go to hey how are you doing today
awesome great weather outside make small
talk make conversation maybe she just
didn't like you and she was harassing
yeah I'm just being Devil's Advocate
can't make conversations because it's
like
it's like it's prevents that I uh my
eyes they make love of course yeah
trying to have conversations like I go
to a restaurant I can't I can't
understand a word you're saying man with
the plexus so I'm a Mexico and we don't
have to wear masks I don't know how it
is at Costco out here so they have the
Plexiglas and the mask and all the
ambient noise around you so what I do is
I go around the foxy glass and I'm like
I can't hear anything you're saying what
are you saying because remember it's
like Kenny from South Park it is yeah
all right polymer says Tim if you truly
believe in his ideals then stop going to
Disney and Marvel movies these companies
hate our values and support this mandate
crap you know honestly that is a good
point not a bad point I stopped doing
Disney stuff I my last trip to Disney
was um after the Mr Olympia my business
partner placed second
um and we went to Disney as families and
it was when they had the mask thing and
it was miserable it's 80 something
degrees out we have these freaking
diapers over our face I'm like I can't
do this and it was weird because Winnie
the Pooh was behind a fence with a mask
on that's weird
that that that that is a truly good
point there's a there's a challenge in
that if I want to know what these movies
and videos are about I have to watch
them so it's hard to just be like I'm
gonna completely cut out all this
content from my life and then not know
anything about it so when issues come up
I'll be like oh you're true but it is it
is it is it is true so I will say like I
don't have a Netflix account I got rid
of that over the cuties thing that's not
not coming back so I don't care for
Netflix it's trash anyway
but uh Disney I do have I do have and I
did cancel before and then I signed up
again because I can't remember what
happened but I was like
something happened with it something I
thought was good and I was like if they
do something good I'll sign back up if
there's something bad I'll cancel it but
the other challenge too is like I want
to be able to watch these shows and then
talk about what they're pushing out
there what they're telling people
if we all cancel if everybody canceled
this is one of the challenge challenges
if everybody canceled Disney they would
just double down on all their garbage
content yeah so it is it is not I don't
know I don't have all the answers man
but I can't say I I actually agree with
polymer about boycotting Disney and
Marvel movies maybe it's to boycott the
movies that are actually pushing the
garbage yeah
Warren B says did anyone watch the movie
don't look up on Netflix I did how was
it uh I think it's great I think look
politics aside I think Leonardo DiCaprio
is one of the greatest actors of all
time so he he lives the role like here's
the thing like the rock is The Rock in
every movie just saying different lines
right Leo DiCaprio and Will Smith and
actors like that they literally become
the part so maybe I'm just enamored with
Leo DiCaprio as an actor but I genuinely
enjoy that movie I do it was a good
movie it was kind of a play on idiocracy
which is pretty interesting I'm not
going to spoil it it's like some people
who spoil movies here I'm not gonna
mention who but it's actually I I
definitely uh it was it was uh thought
provoking enjoyable and
um and and interesting it's different
than a lot of other movies it's about uh
uh what is it a space Rock's gonna slam
into Earth and no one cares basically
yeah and this the scientist is out there
trying to scream they're trying to work
with the White House for it not giving
anything away it's it's just it's a
critique of the government and the media
yeah and it's it's actually and Society
it just sounds like they're complaining
about climate change
while you could make any interpretations
you want with it some people would make
climate change some people would say
covet some people would say energy
policy there's a lot of different
interpretations you could give to it but
it's based on an asteroid you know and
even if there is ulterior motive like
obviously my opinions are based on
education it was entertaining if you're
based and you believe in what you
believe in and you're not big on climate
change it's not going to convert you
it's not going to be like oh my God they
didn't mention climate change it's up
for interpretation do you guys see Ryan
Long's new new sketch hilarious right
right-wing sponsors versus left-wing
sponsors it's really good he's like the
the Patriot podcast he's like we've got
this jug of water it's just Freedom
Water for people who like freedom and
then the left-wing guys like I'm gonna
talk to you about Fair Trade coffee the
segment brought to you by McDonald's so
he he was really really good I thought
that was meant it was uh procured
locally through diversity hires yeah
yeah was it Tyler
yeah Tyler Fisher I think was the one
working with him he also does really
great work and shouts out to him uh we
should maybe even try to get him on the
show I think that would be and then one
of my favorite Parts is when the
left-wing guy is like in his show he
goes I don't like that bunker ties
advertises on the Patriot podcast and
then it shows Ryan long and he's like
unfortunate news bunker ties is no
longer advertising on us I thought that
was Tyler Fisher was the left-wing guy
yeah he's another comedian that does
Great Stuff it's funny how right-wing
companies will
stop sponsoring right-wing shows because
left-wing people who don't buy their
product complain about it and it's it's
not enough people to really matter it's
literally Twitter and if your company is
based on your sales on Twitter you're
screwed anyway I think they see Twitter
as a bigger thing than it is
I really do like the Twitter mob's not
going to put you out of business yep
all right Jackson H says big news Steve
Bannon becomes a strategic partner with
the blockchain media cryptocurrency fjb
he has both invested in the movement as
well as the functionality of the crypto
itself there's not a meme crypto it's a
movement crypto well all right then all
right I'll be sure to invest heavily in
that I'm taking out all my 401ks fjb
coin oh my goodness
Christopher Anne says Tim my little
brother wouldn't come over for Christmas
because I'm unvaxed I've seen him twice
in two years and he lives only an hour
away he's a lefty ever since he went to
college I've lost a brother yep it's
it's crazy to me that people genuinely
think they're gonna die
yeah I mean he scares them let him go I
mean dude no I said I say it's worth
it's worth having those conversations
it's worth not giving up on your family
members it's worth doing your best to
try to inform them because it's your
duty as a loved one if you're close to
someone and they're going down the path
that that is going to eventually lead
them to getting hurt or screwed over by
the establishment it's your duty from my
perspective my opinion I might be wrong
that you gotta help save these people
from understanding and seeing the real
world I'm about removing toxicity and
your brother's stupid all right you have
a point and you might be right we got an
important one here Stephen almarez says
Mark how much push-ups do you do I I I
use dumbbells I use dumbbells and
heavyweights I I train a lot you know
I'm a uh recently two weeks ago I earned
my fbb Pro card which was a huge
undertaking
um took me 41 years to get it
um I train my butt off man I train
really hard a lot of work you know just
like today my priority when I landed I
knew I had time was to get to the gym so
it's a lot so there's there's different
levels of Fitness like you can be in
great shape and look phenomenal training
three days a week now to get to the
level I'm at takes years and years and
years of eating a certain way and
training a certain way and a lot of
other things so it's I do I do a lot of
exercise it's a lot
it's a huge amount now Tim however this
dude was skating like I've never like he
did it was an hour and a half
insane I would have died at like the 10
minute Mark or at least broken something
see there's different levels of
athleticism yeah that I don't know I
could have skated longer but I have to
work I used to skate for eight hours a
day insane yeah it was really brutal
insane I would I would be so I'll be
drenched yeah it was crazy that's
awesome now it's about an hour a day if
you know so sometimes sometimes if it's
like a busy day I'll get a half an hour
and on the half pipe but uh
rollerblading and skateboarding so you
know start with the easy stuff with his
which is just jumping up and getting
airs in the blades and then I switched
to the board and I do the more technical
stuff after I'm all warmed up man that's
a good fun I love that thing just
jumping really high and getting air
that's what it's all about that would
scare me all right
ninja man Fire H says well the highlight
of my holiday was being told I am no
longer welcome to spend time with my
family because of my vac status the
split is real I've heard many similar
things man that's crazy Max Jones says
let's go beat board
super chatted for that I love it how
come alien names are always like with an
X and a z and they can't just be like
you know like Kyle yeah or or not not
even like Kyle but like it's always got
to be a z x or a y it's so foreign it's
not used a lot that's why it's like new
it's alien yeah yeah yeah like kef like
why does it gotta be Z it's like oh
someone some sci-fi guy wrote the you
know Z board and it's like oh what about
like Baba he calls himself butt cheek
yeah it's like the Rick and Morty joke
where the gas alien is like I like that
word fart that's what he calls himself
sprig spidge bandersnatch says you
should ask Sheamus to do a pool family
Thanksgiving sketch Allah his Jordan
Peterson and Ben Shapiro bits that would
be hilarious except Sheamus lacks the
ability to imitate Tim pool that's right
yeah he can't do it he's tried it
doesn't work it's not easy he can't
imitate Joe Rogan either really it's
very hard to to impersonate Joe Rogan
I'm sure it is yeah there's a few people
that it's really hard to get Trump is
actually fairly hard I've seen people
who are really good at Trump but uh some
people are really easy I think Alex
Jones is really easy to impersonate oh
yeah it's about like the way they speak
and if it's a very unique you know it's
very unique it's really easy to get but
if someone has kind of just like a
not the right word is but
average style of talking it's really
hard to impersonate oh yeah yeah I don't
know maybe Sheamus can pull it off I'm
not sure I don't know I don't know if
you can maybe he can maybe he can
bomb choose says I own a location
dependent small business in Southern
Illinois so my best hope would be is the
state breaking in half or possibly just
pushing Cook County into the lake like
at like Atlanta did in Futurama outside
of Cook County Illinois is pretty red
very red you get DuPage yeah you know
and they're they're if it starts getting
a little bit more red but you go you go
south and it's it is red it is a red
state with a blue City in it they're
Farmers it's rural
Nathaniel Meeks says left-wing
complaints about right-wing companies
causing right-wing companies to change
positions from from non-customers sounds
a lot like those wussies over at Black
Rifle coffee that was I saw that I don't
know the whole story of it but I grifted
on it a little because I saw a little
coffee here and there but uh you know
what you just have to stay if your name
is Black Rifle you gotta be well America
no matter what what I heard was that the
New York Times made a claim about what
Black Rifle coffee said and that it was
not true it was fake news where's the
lawsuit then I would have sued the pants
off but it's but it's you you can't this
is the this is the thing man these these
news organizations are very very clever
you could make a statement and they'll
frame it in a way to change the context
of what you said and make it so what I
what my understanding was and I don't
know anything about it because we'll be
honest no was that they made a comment
the New York Times misframed and then
everyone got mad at them and they were
like dude why do you guys believe the
New York Times their fake news
okay then I take it back oh I don't know
I'm not trying to defend them because
that like as if I know I don't know I'm
just saying that's one thing I've heard
so trying to give the other side here
not that I I don't I don't have Black
Rifle coffee I've never even tasted it
I've never tried it yeah I only think
about it
all right Rick M says why not stop it
why stop at Marvel Disney Etc the
biggest change could come from not
buying Chinese products it would impact
the future the most you can't you can't
stay in business without buying Chinese
products that's what people do don't
don't know businesses don't realize we
do not have the manufacturing
capabilities in any other country
including America to replace China China
is an invaluable resource we have to
have trade with China or we hurt as much
as they do unless we start slowly
pushing towards bringing back
manufacturing well we need to push
towards being back manufacturing and
make the choices when you can I can't
cut off China no business owner from a
local cookie store to a friggin larger
company like mine can cut off China
what we can do is Select things for
example our clothing went from China to
domestic and Pakistan so there are ways
to get around China but cutting off
China as you type into your smartphone
or your computer that's probably made in
China yep you know we can't do it we are
too reliant on China right now yeah we
should be working with India uh
dramatically geopolitically but we're
not for some reason and the foreign
policy of America is pushing India away
towards Russia's hand all right
everybody if you haven't already smash
that like button right now do it for Ian
who's not here today and he can't be
here to ask so smash that like button
for him and subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends go to
timcast.com become a member because at
about 11 or so PM we will put up our
members only show at timcast.com because
some people have asked like wait where's
it at on the website and you can follow
the show timcast IRL basically
everywhere follow us on Instagram for
Clips you can follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at timcast Mark you want to
shout out social media or your website
yeah of course tigerfitness.com you can
buy your outright bars all my other
supplements it's a fantastic site you
can find me on social media youtube.com
tigerfitness
um and every other social media is at
Mark lobliner Marc l-o-bism boy
l-i-n-e-r Mark that was great thank you
so much for coming and if you want to
hear more about me about Bebop 2024 the
Trump fauchi Alliance and other
government psyops you can by checking
out my YouTube channel on youtube.com
forward slash we are change.org I also
produce videos on Luke uncensored.com
hope to see some of you guys there
thanks so much for having me it was
always a joy and pleasure who's gonna
make the beat 2024 shirts my guys are
already on it I got great designers here
I'm like I'm talking to them right now
it's like nice
I like that one too I just wanted to say
Tim mentioned earlier that there's no
thing nothing more permanent than a
temporary government program and he
failed to mention that the Social
Security Administration was initially
temporary so wow so you know it was
supposed to be temporary so uh if in
case you're curious what we're getting
into I'm a little bit worried about that
but I guess we'll have to see what
happens you guys may follow me on
Twitter at Sour Patch let's
this is a holiday week man the week
prior nobody's working people are still
not working I'm surprised we're working
uh we're not going to be here Friday
because it's New Year's Eve and to be
honest it's just impossible to get
people to want to come on a show because
they're like dude I'm going partying are
you nuts and so everybody should go out
and have a good New Year's Eve
celebration that being said we will be
back tomorrow and we will see you all at
the in the in the members only segment
at timcast.com 11 p.m thanks for hanging
out bye guys